Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, add free listening, early access to series and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to the rest ishistory.com and join the club. That is the rest is history.com. This episode is brought to you by SAP. With investors, customers, and workers demanding more from your business, it's time to try SAP. Its AI-powered capabilities can help you streamline costs, connect with new suppliers and manage payroll
感谢您收听《历史的余味》（The Rest is History）。如需每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。本期节目由 SAP 赞助。随着投资者、客户和员工对您的业务提出更高要求，是时候尝试 SAP 了。其人工智能驱动的功能可以帮助您精简成本、对接新供应商并管理薪资。
even when your business is being pulled in different directions to deliver a quality product at a fair price while paying your people what they're worth too so your business can stay unfazed learn more at SAP.com slash uncertainty When you're with Amex Platinum you get access to exclusive dining experiences and an annual travel credit
即使您的业务在多方压力下，既要以合理的价格提供优质产品，又要给予员工应有的报酬，SAP 也能让您的业务保持从容不迫。欲了解更多信息，请访问 SAP.com/uncertainty。当您拥有美国运通白金卡（Amex Platinum）时，您将获得独家餐饮体验和年度旅行抵用金。
so the best tap is in town might be in a new town altogether. That's the powerful backing of Amex. Terms and conditions apply. Learn more at amex.ca. slash yamex. This episode is brought to you by Hive. You know, history is full of transformations.
所以，城里最好的小酒馆可能就在一个全新的城镇。这就是美国运通强大的后盾。条款与细则适用。欲了解更多信息，请访问 amex.ca/yamex。本期节目由 Hive 赞助。你知道，历史充满了变革。
The Romans shifted from Republic to Empire. The Tudors transformed monasteries into country houses. And do you know, what, Hive has had one of its own. Everybody knows Hive for smart thermostats, but now they've evolved into something much greater. Solar panels that help you to power your home with clean energy, heat pumps that pull warmth from thin air, EV charges that charge your car while you're asleep, all managed through a single app. This is all about giving people the power to transform their homes, from waste to efficiency, from dependence to control, from consumption to
罗马人从共和国转变为帝国。都铎王朝将修道院改造成了乡村别墅。你知道吗，Hive 也经历了自己的变革。每个人都知道 Hive 的智能恒温器，但现在他们已经进化成了更伟大的事物。太阳能电池板帮助您用清洁能源为家庭供电，热泵从空气中汲取热量，电动汽车充电桩在您睡眠时为您的汽车充电，所有这些都通过一个应用程序进行管理。这一切都是为了赋予人们改变家庭的力量，从浪费到高效，从依赖到掌控，从消费到
contribution. So history's next great transformation may not be happening in parliaments or palaces. It may be happening in your home. A quiet revolution minus guillotine's. Hive. Know your power. Visit hivehome.com to find out more, subject to survey and suitability. Hive app compatible with selected heat pumps. Seathing with tension in the shadow of Mount Fusuvius. Naples was one of the most glamorous and violent cities on earth. It was a city of churches and opera houses, coffee bars and ice cream parlors,
贡献。所以，历史下一次伟大的变革可能不会发生在议会或宫殿里。它可能就发生在您的家里。一场没有断头台的宁静革命。Hive。掌握您的力量。访问 hivehome.com 了解更多信息，视勘测和适用性而定。Hive 应用程序兼容选定的热泵。在维苏威火山的阴影下，空气中弥漫着紧张的气氛。那不勒斯是地球上最迷人也最暴力的城市之一。这是一座教堂和歌剧院、咖啡馆和冰淇淋店林立的城市，
graceful squares and shadowed alleys. elegant mansions and stinking slums. It was home to scholars and thieves, monks and musicians, princesses and dancing girls. It was a hotbed of crime where a wrong turn could mean a knife in the ribs, but it was also a city of pleasure where every night was rich with possibility. Above it all towered the volcano. Sometimes when it smolded at night, you could see flashes of fire near the summit and taste the acrid smoke in the air. That was part of the city's glamour too. The sense of danger, the shadow of death. As the fangarde sailed into the harbour on a bright Saturday morning in September 1798, danger and death were very far from the mind of Nelson.
优雅的广场和阴暗的小巷。华丽的宅邸和恶臭的贫民窟。这里是学者与窃贼、僧侣与音乐家、公主与舞女的家园。这是一个犯罪的温床，走错一步可能就意味着肋骨上挨一刀，但它也是一座享乐之城，每个夜晚都充满了无限可能。火山耸立在这一切之上。有时，当它在夜间闷烧时，你可以看到山顶附近的火光，并尝到空气中刺鼻的烟味。这也是这座城市魅力的一部分。危险的感觉，死亡的阴影。当“先锋号”（Vanguard）在 1798 年 9 月一个明亮的周六早晨驶入港口时，纳尔逊的脑海中离危险和死亡还非常遥远。
Yet although he could hardly have known it, one of the darkest chapters in his life was about to begin. So that is from one of the great biographies of Admiral Horatio Nelson. Adventures in Time, Nelson, Hero of the Seas, published in paperback this Thursday and written by the rest is history's very own Dominic Sambrook. And it describes the moment on Saturday the 22nd of September, 1798, when Horatio Nelson, Victor of the Nile, limps into Naples to kick off one of the most melodramed. dramatic and blood-soaked and controversial episodes of his entire life. And I say limped because rather embarrassingly, its masts had been smashed up in a storm. And so the vanguard had to be towed into the Bay of Naples. And Dominic, we described this scene in our most recent episode
然而，尽管他几乎不可能知道，他生命中最黑暗的篇章之一即将开始。以上内容摘自霍雷肖·纳尔逊海军上将的伟大传记之一。《时间冒险：纳尔逊，海洋英雄》（Adventures in Time, Nelson, Hero of the Seas），本周四出版平装本，由《历史的余味》主持人多米尼克·桑布鲁克（Dominic Sandbrook）撰写。书中描述了 1798 年 9 月 22 日星期六，尼罗河之战的胜利者霍雷肖·纳尔逊一瘸一拐地走进那不勒斯，开启了他一生中最具戏剧性、血腥且充满争议的篇章之一。我说“一瘸一拐”是因为，相当尴尬的是，他的桅杆在风暴中被撞坏了。所以“先锋号”不得不被拖进那不勒斯湾。多米尼克，我们在最近的一期节目中描述过这个场景，
where we were telling the story of Emma Hamilton, the housemaid, prostitute, kept mistress who rose from the slums of the Industrial Revolution and London to the palaces of southern Italy. And that rise has put her in pole position to greet Horatio Nelson, the hero of the Battle of the Nile, the most celebrated hero in Britain, Napoleon's most feared enemy as he arrives into Naples. And if we did Emma Hamilton in our last episode, then last year we did a five-part series on Nelson, didn't we? And this is going to be the continuation. It is exactly, Tom. So, hello, everybody. Many of you will remember that we did that season on Nelson last year. So we traced his story from his birth in 1758, in a Norfolk Vicarage. He joined the Royal Navy as a teenager, effectively. He rose up the ranks. He became a national. national hero for the first time after showing enormous courage at the Battle of Capes and Vincent. Captures two ships, doesn't he? Captures two ships, leaping from ship to ship. An amazing swashbuckling
当时我们讲述了艾玛·汉密尔顿（Emma Hamilton）的故事，这位从工业革命时期的伦敦贫民窟崛起，最终进入意大利南部宫殿的女仆、妓女和被包养的情妇。这次崛起使她处于迎接霍雷肖·纳尔逊的绝佳位置，他是尼罗河之战的英雄，英国最著名的英雄，也是拿破仑最恐惧的敌人，当他抵达那不勒斯时。如果我们上一期节目讲了艾玛·汉密尔顿，那么去年我们做了一个关于纳尔逊的五集系列节目，对吧？而这将是续篇。正是如此，汤姆。那么，大家好。你们中的许多人会记得我们去年制作了那个关于纳尔逊的系列节目。我们追溯了他从 1758 年出生在诺福克郡一个牧师家庭开始的故事。他十几岁时就加入了皇家海军。他不断晋升。在圣文森特角战役中表现出巨大的勇气后，他第一次成为了民族英雄。他俘获了两艘船，不是吗？他从一艘船跳到另一艘船。一个令人惊叹的剑客
scene. And then his kind of patriotic apotheosis, that's where we ended the last series. In 1798, he has pursued the French fleet, the armament, as it was called, across the Mediterranean. He has found them at Abukir Bay near the mouth of the Nile. And he has destroyed the them in this fantastic kind of scene, this night attack. And we will be telling the story in this series of what happens next, the last seven years of his life. And there is so much to say, isn't there? Because we've got the scandalous relationship with Emma. We've got revolution and counter-revolution in Naples, very controversial. We've got the Battle of Copenhagen, where he puts his telescope to his wrong eye. And then, of course, we will be visiting.
场景。然后是他那种爱国主义的升华，那是我们上一季结束的地方。1798 年，他一直在地中海追击法国舰队，即所谓的“武装舰队”。他在尼罗河口附近的阿布基尔湾发现了他们。他在这个奇妙的场景中，在这次夜袭中摧毁了他们。我们将在本系列中讲述接下来发生的事情，他生命的最后七年。有很多话要说，不是吗？因为我们有与艾玛的丑闻关系。我们有那不勒斯的革命和反革命，非常有争议。我们有哥本哈根战役，他在那里把望远镜放在了错误的眼睛上。然后，当然，我们将访问
his great victory and death at Trafalgar. So, so much to look forward to. Yeah, one of the great epics in, I mean, the great epic, a lot of his biographers would argue, in English and in British kind of military naval and indeed all history, I would say. I think it's my favourite story in British history. Well, there's lots of controversial moments on which Tom, you and I disagree. I think it's fair to say. We're going to disagree agreeably, aren't we?
他在特拉法加的伟大胜利和死亡。所以，有很多值得期待的内容。是的，这是伟大的史诗之一，我的意思是，很多传记作者会认为，这是英语和英国军事、海军乃至所有历史中的伟大史诗。我认为这是我最喜欢的英国历史故事。嗯，汤姆，你和我对很多有争议的时刻有分歧。我认为这样说很公平。我们将以友好的方式产生分歧，不是吗？
Yeah, like they're doing the rest is politics. That's exciting. Anyway, let's remind ourselves where we ended the last series. So Nelson is about to turn 40. He is this famously, physically, slight and sickly character. He has lost his right arm because he was shot in the elbow. And he has lost the sight in one of his eyes, though not the eye itself. I know you want to point out, Tom, that he doesn't look like a pirate.
是的，就像他们在《政治的余味》（The Rest is Politics）中所做的那样。那很令人兴奋。无论如何，让我们回顾一下我们上一季结束的地方。纳尔逊即将年满 40 岁。他是一个众所周知的、身体瘦弱且多病的角色。他失去了右臂，因为他的肘部中弹了。他失去了一只眼睛的视力，虽然不是眼睛本身。我知道你想指出，汤姆，他看起来不像海盗。
No, he doesn't wear an eye patch. He wears neither an eye patch nor a sort of hook instead of a hand. I think he would have been better if he'd had. Well, important when we come to the Battle of Copenhagen where he puts his telescope to his wrong eye, or does he, he's not wearing an eye patch. That's what listeners have to bear in mind. He has won the Battle of the Nile.
不，他不戴眼罩。他既不戴眼罩，也没有用钩子代替手。我想如果他有的话会更好。嗯，这在我们谈到哥本哈根战役时很重要，他在那里把望远镜放在了错误的眼睛上，或者他真的那样做了吗？他没有戴眼罩。这就是听众必须记住的。他赢得了尼罗河之战。
He has destroyed Napoleon's fleet. It is the most stunning victory in British naval history. The only reason it's not better known today is because I think it's eclipsed in the public imagination by Trafalgar. Nelson had not lost a single ship. He had captured or destroyed 11 out of the 13. French battleships. This meant that Napoleon was stranded in Egypt, that he was cut off from France, and this victory gave Britain control of the Mediterranean. I mean, arguably, you could
他摧毁了拿破仑的舰队。这是英国海军史上最令人震惊的胜利。它今天之所以不那么出名，是因为我认为它在公众想象中被特拉法加战役掩盖了。纳尔逊没有损失一艘船。他俘获或摧毁了 13 艘法国战列舰中的 11 艘。这意味着拿破仑被困在埃及，他与法国隔绝，而这场胜利使英国控制了地中海。我的意思是，可以说，
argue for a generation, and indeed for good. And they had lost that control to the French fleet two years before. So this is a stunning reversal of fortune. Exactly. When the news reached England, there was this explosion of patriotic joy. So his wife, Nelson, is married, of course, He has a wife called Fanny, whom he met in the Caribbean. She's been waiting with his elderly father, the Reverend Edmund Nelson, and they are delighted when they get the news. And everybody is delighted. There are fireworks. There are bonfires.
你可以争辩说这持续了一代人，甚至永远。而他们两年前刚刚失去了对法国舰队的控制。所以这是一个惊人的命运逆转。正是如此。当消息传到英国时，爆发了爱国主义的狂欢。所以他的妻子，纳尔逊当然结婚了，他有一个叫范妮（Fanny）的妻子，他在加勒比海认识了她。她一直和他的老父亲埃德蒙·纳尔逊牧师（Reverend Edmund Nelson）在一起等待，当他们得到消息时，他们非常高兴。每个人都很高兴。有烟花。有篝火。
There are flags. There are balls. It is a tremendous moment. It's sort of one of those great memorable national occasions, the news of the Battle of the Nile. Now, George III rewarded Nelson with a barony. Nelson being Nelson, he has a kind of diva quality. He is disappointed because he wanted of Icouncy. I mean, he doesn't get it, does he?
有旗帜。有舞会。这是一个巨大的时刻。这是那些令人难忘的伟大国家盛事之一，尼罗河之战的消息。现在，乔治三世授予纳尔逊男爵爵位。纳尔逊毕竟是纳尔逊，他有一种天后的特质。他很失望，因为他想要子爵爵位。我的意思是，他没有得到，对吧？
Because George III worries that he doesn't have the funds to sustain of Icouncy. Exactly. And Nelson's problems with money will be a kind of running theme through this series. However, the advantage of being a baron, I gather, is that he can, from this point on, sign himself not as Horatio Nelson, but as Nelson. So he's not gone home. This is an important point. He's staying away for much longer. Why? For a couple of reasons. First of all, his own ships have been badly damaged. So, as you said, Tom, not just the vanguard, but the Alexander and the Colloden are in a terrible state. And Naples is the kind of nearest safe, friendly harbour where they can be repaired. But also, Naples is an absolutely crucial ally for Britain in the Mediterranean. Because the Mediterranean up to this point has been very much a kind of French lake. And so Britain has been desperate to
因为乔治三世担心他没有足够的资金来维持子爵爵位。正是如此。而纳尔逊的金钱问题将成为本系列的一个贯穿主题。然而，我了解到，成为男爵的好处是，从这一点开始，他可以不再以霍雷肖·纳尔逊的名义签名，而是以“纳尔逊”的名义签名。所以他没有回家。这是一个重要的点。他还要在外面待很长时间。为什么？有两个原因。首先，他自己的船只受损严重。所以，正如你所说的，汤姆，不仅是“先锋号”，还有“亚历山大号”和“卡洛登号”都处于糟糕的状态。而那不勒斯是最近的安全、友好的港口，他们可以在那里进行维修。但同时，那不勒斯也是英国在地中海绝对关键的盟友。因为地中海到目前为止在很大程度上一直是一种“法国湖”。所以英国一直迫切需要
find and preserve the fragile alliances that it has. So maybe we should talk a little bit about Naples. So you did that lovely reading. I mean, what else is there to say? So you know what? There's loads to say. Well, take it away. So Naples is the capital of the kingdom of the two Sicilus. And that's been independent of Austria for about 60 years. Naples is the third biggest city in Europe. It has about a third of a million people living in the shadow of the volcano. As you described, as all Nelson's biographers describe, it has this unique sort of atmosphere that it has, I guess, to this day,
寻找并维护它所拥有的脆弱联盟。所以也许我们应该谈谈那不勒斯。你读了那段优美的文字。我的意思是，还有什么可说的？你知道吗？有很多可说的。嗯，你接着说。所以那不勒斯是两西西里王国的首都。它已经从奥地利独立了大约 60 年。那不勒斯是欧洲第三大城市。有大约三十万人生活在火山的阴影下。正如你所描述的，正如所有纳尔逊的传记作者所描述的那样，它有一种独特的氛围，我想，直到今天，
this sense of danger and excitement, the sort of narrow alleys, the great palaces, all of this kind of thing. I think it remains to this day the one city in Europe that if you go to it as another European, it genuinely feels foreign. Yes.
这种危险和兴奋的感觉，那种狭窄的小巷，宏伟的宫殿，所有这些东西。我认为它至今仍然是欧洲唯一的一座城市，如果你作为另一个欧洲人去那里，它确实感觉很陌生。是的。
I've always thought the most almost Latin American city in Europe. That sort of atmosphere, extremes of wealth and property. great excitement and exoticism, but also, you know, there's a very good chance you will leave without your wallet. Our Latin American listeners will be so offended by that. I withdraw that comment. It's a thrilling, faintly dangerous place.
我一直认为它是欧洲最接近拉丁美洲的城市。那种氛围，财富和财产的极端。巨大的兴奋和异国情调，但也，你知道，你很有可能在离开时钱包就不见了。我们的拉丁美洲听众会因为那个而感到被冒犯。我收回那个评论。这是一个令人兴奋、略带危险的地方。
Exactly. So it's not really Nelson's kind of place, actually, because Nelson, in many ways, up to this point, has been quite a puritanical character, I would say. He's not a tremendous carouser. He works very hard. He broods. He wears about his health. he's not really the person you would take on a night out, I would say. He will come to love it. I mean, that's the striking thing for reasons that we will be exploring. But he later called it a country of fiddlers and poets, whores and scoundrels. And that gives you a sense of, I think, how a lot of people in the Royal Navy thought about Naples.
正是如此。所以这其实并不是纳尔逊喜欢的地方，因为纳尔逊在很多方面，到目前为止，一直是一个相当清教徒式的角色，我会说。他不是一个狂欢者。他工作非常努力。他沉思。他担心自己的健康。他真的不是那种你会带去参加夜生活的人，我会说。他后来会爱上它。我的意思是，这是令人震惊的事情，原因我们将进行探讨。但他后来称它为“提琴手和诗人、妓女和无赖的国家”。这让你感觉到，我想，皇家海军中的许多人是如何看待那不勒斯的。
Well, I think they see Naples and indeed Italy as a kind of seductive woman. Exactly. Yes. So Naples, supposedly, it's also named Parthenope, after one of the sirens who had suggested. and that sense of it as a city that seduces and corrupts again is an important part of the story I think. Now, Nelson has been to Naples before. He went since 1793 during the siege of Toulon when Admiral Hood, one of his mentors, sent him to ask for supplies and reinforcements. And back then, he made a very favourable impression on the British envoy to Naples, the British
嗯，我认为他们把那不勒斯乃至意大利看作是一个诱人的女人。正是如此。是的。所以那不勒斯，据说是以帕耳忒诺珀（Parthenope）命名的，她是那些诱惑者之一。而那种它作为一座诱惑和腐蚀城市的意义，我认为也是故事的重要组成部分。现在，纳尔逊以前去过那不勒斯。他在 1793 年土伦围城战期间去过，当时他的导师之一胡德海军上将（Admiral Hood）派他去请求补给和增援。那时，他给英国驻那不勒斯公使留下了非常好的印象，英国
minister in Naples, who's Sir William Hamilton, and his wife Emma, whom you described in our previous episode. So there's the Hamilton's, we'll come to them. But the other key figures for Nelson are the royal couple, the king and queen of Naples. Again, we talked about them last time, Ferdinand IV and Maria Carolina. Ferdinand the fourth, he's this absolute buffoon of a man, he's a total oaf. He forces his coachman to eat live frogs. He chases people around with an overflowing chamber pot. He spends all this time hunting. His Franz Ferdinand without all the good bits. Yeah, without the good bits. And he's got, he talks like a woman. He does. He got a high voice. Unlike, and his wife talks like a man. Maria Carolina, who is a Habsburg, an Austrian, and importantly, the older sister of Marie Antoinette. Now, she is quite a serious person. She's effectively been running the state for the last 20 years or so. She is smart. She is ruthless. And for her, opposition to France, it's not merely political. It is personal. I should
驻那不勒斯大臣，也就是威廉·汉密尔顿爵士（Sir William Hamilton），以及他的妻子艾玛，你在上一集描述过她。所以这就是汉密尔顿夫妇，我们稍后会谈到他们。但对纳尔逊来说，其他关键人物是那不勒斯的国王和王后。我们上次也谈到了他们，费迪南德四世（Ferdinand IV）和玛丽亚·卡罗琳娜（Maria Carolina）。费迪南德四世，他是一个绝对的笨蛋，他是一个彻头彻尾的傻瓜。他强迫他的马车夫吃活青蛙。他拿着一个溢出的便盆在后面追人。他把所有时间都花在打猎上。他是没有优点的弗朗茨·费迪南德。是的，没有优点。而且他说话像个女人。他确实。他声音很高。不像，而他的妻子说话像个男人。玛丽亚·卡罗琳娜，她是哈布斯堡家族的人，奥地利人，重要的是，她是玛丽·安托瓦内特（Marie Antoinette）的姐姐。现在，她是一个相当严肃的人。她实际上在过去 20 年左右的时间里一直在管理国家。她很聪明。她很无情。对她来说，反对法国，不仅仅是政治上的。这是个人的。我应该
always regard them as the murderers of my sister, Mariantoinette, as the oppressors of all monarchies, as the villains who have seduced and put dagger and poison into the hands of all classes and peoples against legitimate authority and who have blighted my existence. This is really, really deep-seated with her. Why wouldn't it be? They've killed her sister. It makes sense. I mean, of course, but at the same time, all the social circumstances that existed in Paris and had fostered revolutionary sentiment exist even more in Naples. Because there you have, again, you have a kind of feudal system that is patently in decline. And the gap between the very rich in their palazos, enjoying their classical statuary, and so on. And the people in the slums
永远把他们视为我姐姐玛丽·安托瓦内特的谋杀者，视为所有君主制的压迫者，视为那些诱惑并把匕首和毒药交到所有阶级和人民手中以对抗合法权威，并毁掉我生存的恶棍。这对她来说是非常根深蒂固的。为什么不呢？他们杀了她的姐姐。这说得通。我的意思是，当然，但与此同时，巴黎存在的所有社会环境以及助长革命情绪的环境在那不勒斯甚至更加严重。因为在那里，你再次拥有了一种显然在衰落的封建制度。而那些在宫殿里享受古典雕像等的极度富有的人，与贫民窟里的人之间的差距
is very, very wide. So in a sense, Dominic, it's a tinderbox. I knew the tinderbox was coming. I could just see the tinderbox coming from. The spark of revolution is waiting to be draft. Four sentences off. I thought, there's a tender box coming. Well, here's the interesting thing about Naples that I think it's important for people to get into their heads. So on the one hand, you do have very rich, very reactionary people at the top and whatnot, but you also have an enlightened elite. So a kind of, you know, your liberal metropolitan elite, if you like. Do you know, I heard that phrase coming. You saw that coming. Yeah, because you did. Of course you did. Well, listen, I mean, there's one thing about the rest of this history is, you know,
非常非常大。所以从某种意义上说，多米尼克，这是一个火药桶。我知道火药桶要来了。我简直能看到火药桶要来了。革命的火花正等着被点燃。离四句话远。我想，火药桶要来了。好吧，关于那不勒斯，我认为人们需要记住的一件有趣的事情是。所以一方面，你确实有顶层非常富有、非常反动的人等等，但你也有一个开明的精英阶层。所以一种，你知道，你的自由派大都市精英，如果你愿意的话。你知道吗，我听到了那个短语要来了。你预见到了。是的，因为你确实预见到了。当然你预见到了。好吧，听着，我的意思是，关于《历史的余味》有一件事是，你知道，
There's only 10 phrases in the English language, and we like to use them all often. So these are people who are, I know this is, I hate to say it, you can see this coming as well, poets, writers, prune juice drinkers, do they wear sandals, intellectuals of all kinds? Unlike the honest, rough beggars and poor people who love the royal family. Well, this is an important distinction, right? On the one hand, you have these people who are called in the books, the Jacobin. I mean, they're not really Jacques-a-Man, but that's the label that is kind of attached to them. And they are reformers, they're enlightened, they're infused with the ideals of the French Revolution.
英语中只有 10 个短语，我们喜欢经常使用它们。所以这些人是，我知道这是，我讨厌这么说，你也能预见到这一点，诗人、作家、喝西梅汁的人，他们穿凉鞋吗，各种各样的知识分子？不像那些热爱皇室的诚实、粗鲁的乞丐和穷人。嗯，这是一个重要的区别，对吧？一方面，你有这些人，在书中被称为“雅各宾派”。我的意思是，他们并不是真正的雅各宾派，但那是贴在他们身上的标签。他们是改革者，他们是开明的，他们被法国大革命的理想所熏陶。
They're probably, you know, they're the people who are most similar to the presenters of this podcast. But then on the other hand, you have these people called the Lazzaroni. And these are beggars and street urchins and they're kind of the raucous mob of the streets. Now, they're not quite the same as the Sonsculot. in Paris, because as we discussed in our French Revolution series, the Sumpcalotte are actually not the very poorest, whereas the Lazzaroni are. They like to dress very colourfully. They're the kind of people that, if you're going on a grand tour, and you go into Naples,
他们可能，你知道，他们是与这个播客的主持人最相似的人。但另一方面，你有这些人被称为“拉扎罗尼”（Lazzaroni）。这些是乞丐和街头顽童，他们是街头喧闹的暴民。现在，他们和巴黎的“无套裤汉”（Sans-culottes）不太一样，因为正如我们在法国大革命系列中所讨论的那样，无套裤汉实际上并不是最贫穷的人，而拉扎罗尼却是。他们喜欢穿得非常鲜艳。他们是那种人，如果你去进行大巡游，你去那不勒斯，
they're the people you want to look at. You know, oh, ha la, look at their exotic costumes and their sort of filthy ways. And one of the kind of the attitudes, the shows that Emma Hamilton puts on is to dress up as one of the urban poor and do a native dance. That's so tasteful. Oh, that's lovely. That reflects so well on her, Tom. Well, the queen loves it and the people love their queen.
他们是你想要看的人。你知道，哦，看他们异国情调的服装和他们那种肮脏的方式。而艾玛·汉密尔顿表演的一种态度，就是打扮成城市贫民的样子，跳一种土著舞蹈。那真是太有品位了。哦，那太可爱了。那对她来说反映得太好了，汤姆。嗯，王后喜欢它，人民也爱他们的王后。
Yeah, or the rich people love it, no doubt. The people love their queen. So, but here's the thing. These people do love the king and queen. They are very, very pro monarchy. They are very, frankly, very reactionary. They're the kind of the populists of the streets. So you've got this sort of tension.
是的，或者富人喜欢它，毫无疑问。人民爱他们的王后。所以，但这就是重点。这些人确实爱国王和王后。他们非常非常支持君主制。他们坦率地说，非常反动。他们是街头的民粹主义者。所以你有这种紧张关系。
This is the cauldron, seething with tension. It's bubbling over. It's bubbly. but not quite bubbling, but it's simmering, into which Nelson arrives in September 1798. Now, as we described last time, when the vanguard has towed into the harbour, the city is already celebrating. And the reason it's celebrating is that Naples has lived in the shadow of the possibility of a French attack, because the French have, since the late 1790s, they've been pouring through Italy. They have taken Rome quite recently. Yeah, just earlier in the air, wasn't it?
这就是大锅，弥漫着紧张。它正在沸腾。它在冒泡。但还没有完全冒泡，但它在煨，纳尔逊于 1798 年 9 月抵达这里。现在，正如我们上次所描述的，当“先锋号”被拖进港口时，城市已经在庆祝了。它庆祝的原因是那不勒斯一直生活在法国可能发动袭击的阴影下，因为法国人自 1790 年代末以来，一直在涌入意大利。他们最近刚刚占领了罗马。是的，就在今年早些时候，不是吗？
Yeah. And the Neapolitans are frightened. that the French will keep going and they see Nelson therefore as their great liberator But there is, I mean there is a kind of tension A problem here for the king and queen Which is obviously they're pro-British They want to give Nelson the warmest welcome they possibly can
是的。那不勒斯人很害怕。法国人会继续前进，因此他们把纳尔逊视为他们伟大的解放者。但这里有一种紧张，一个问题，对国王和王后来说，显然他们是亲英派。他们想给纳尔逊尽可能热烈的欢迎
But officially they're neutral And if they openly celebrate Nelson Then that might be a kind of Kassas, their lie And this I think is where Emma comes in Because she can celebrate Nelson because she herself is British. And her association with the King and Queen make it clear that she is kind of speaking for them.
但官方他们是中立的。如果他们公开庆祝纳尔逊，那么那可能是一种战争借口。而我认为这就是艾玛发挥作用的地方。因为她可以庆祝纳尔逊，因为她本人是英国人。而她与国王和王后的联系使她清楚地表明，她是在为他们代言。
And so she organises this great fiesta. She parades Nelson through the streets in a carriage and all the crowds go wild for him. And really the King and Queen thereby are enabled to have the best of both worlds. They celebrate Nelson, but they don't piss off the French. Yeah, although they're pretty blatant themselves. So Ferdinand and Maria Carolina actually greeted Nelson in the harbour
所以她组织了这场盛大的节日。她用马车带着纳尔逊穿过街道，所有人群都为他疯狂。而国王和王后因此能够两全其美。他们庆祝纳尔逊，但他们没有激怒法国人。是的，尽管他们自己相当明目张胆。所以费迪南德和玛丽亚·卡罗琳娜实际上在港口迎接了纳尔逊
and came for breakfast. They had a big breakfast. public. I mean, it's not kind of... No, in private, I guess. But the crowds, you know, they're shouting Viva Nelson, Nostro Libertore. There are banquets and balls, and of all these balls, which are enormous by Neapolitan standards, the most famous is thrown inevitably over the Hamilton's themselves. So just to remind people, if there's anybody who didn't listen to our last episode, Sir William Hamilton is 67 years old. He's this kind of tall, beaky, cerebral, sophisticated, detached, ironic character
并来吃早餐。他们吃了一顿丰盛的早餐。公开的。我的意思是，这不是那种……不，私下里，我想。但人群，你知道，他们在喊“纳尔逊万岁，我们的解放者”（Viva Nelson, Nostro Libertore）。有宴会和舞会，而在所有这些舞会上，按那不勒斯的标准来看是巨大的，最著名的是不可避免地由汉密尔顿夫妇自己举办的。所以提醒一下人们，如果有人没有听我们上一集，威廉·汉密尔顿爵士已经 67 岁了。他是一个高大、鹰钩鼻、理智、世故、超脱、讽刺的角色
who's been Britain's man in Naples for, what, almost 30 years? And Emma, 34, as you said, she is a former prostitute. She's come from an excruciatingly poor and deprived background. And she has advanced, thanks to her charisma and her charm
他在那不勒斯担任英国代表已经，什么，快 30 年了？而艾玛，34 岁，正如你所说，她是一个前妓女。她来自一个极其贫困和匮乏的背景。而她已经进步了，多亏了她的魅力和吸引力
and her sense of glamour, I guess. The excitement that surrounds us. She's a celebrity. She is. She's an international. celebrity. Like Nelson, of course. Yes. Well, we'll see there's there are definite similarities. So they throw, for example, a massive party for his birthday, thousands of guests, special crockery decorated with Nelson's monogram. There's this sort of great sense of excitement. And Emma
以及她的魅力感，我想。围绕着我们的兴奋。她是一个名人。她是。她是一个国际名人。像纳尔逊一样，当然。是的。嗯，我们会看到，肯定有相似之处。所以他们举办了，例如，一个为他生日举办的盛大派对，数千名客人，装饰着纳尔逊字母组合的特殊陶器。有一种巨大的兴奋感。而艾玛
throws herself into this. So she dresses up in a kind of Nelson themed costume, doesn't she? Yeah. And it is very clear that this, I think, you know, Nelson. The Nelson always, let's be frank, we're great fans of Nelson, but Nelson is far from perfect. So Nelson always had a susceptibility to flattery and a thirst, an insatiable thirst for attention. And for somebody who has just been on this, you know, this incredibly grueling mission, chasing the fleet across the Mediterranean, then the drama and excitement of the Battle of the Nile, the enemy ship, L'Oryon, exploding in front of. of him, hundreds of people being killed, all of this. He's still got concussion by some accounts. You know, he has been hit in the head, hasn't he, by a... Yeah, so he's got a great chunk of his scalp has missing. He's got kind of a bit of
全身心地投入其中。所以她打扮成一种纳尔逊主题的服装，不是吗？是的。而且很明显，这，我想，你知道，纳尔逊。纳尔逊总是，让我们坦率地说，我们是纳尔逊的忠实粉丝，但纳尔逊远非完美。所以纳尔逊总是对奉承有易感性，并且有一种渴望，一种对关注的贪得无厌的渴望。而对于一个刚刚经历了，你知道，这个极其艰苦的任务，在地中海追击舰队，然后是尼罗河之战的戏剧性和兴奋，敌舰“东方号”（L'Orient）在他面前爆炸，数百人被杀，所有这些。他甚至还有脑震荡，根据一些说法。你知道，他头部被击中了，不是吗，被一个……是的，所以他头皮的一大块不见了。他有一种
flying metal hit it. So if you imagine psychologically, right, he arrives in this city, very exciting place. He's greeted by these very glamorous people. He's taken to balls and parties that are all about him. His head is kind of whirling the whole time. And it does, I think, slightly go to his head. I mean, he admits this himself. He says it was the most distinguished reception that ever, I believe, fell to the lot of any human being. That's quite a big thing to say of yourself. He wrote to his father at one point and said, it is enough to make me vain. And I think there's a degree of self-knowledge there. I mean, he's pretty vain, as it, even before it started. But he's also getting presents and things from foreign monarchs. The most famous is the thing called
飞溅的金属击中了它。所以如果你在心理上想象一下，对吧，他抵达了这个城市，一个非常令人兴奋的地方。他受到这些非常迷人的人的迎接。他被带到舞会和派对上，所有这些都是关于他的。他的头一直处于眩晕状态。而且我认为，这确实稍微冲昏了他的头脑。我的意思是，他自己也承认这一点。他说：“这是我相信任何人类所能得到的最高贵的接待。”对自己说这样的话是很了不起的。他有一次写信给他的父亲说：“这足以让我变得虚荣。”我认为那里有一种自我认识。我的意思是，他很虚荣，即使在它开始之前。但他还从外国君主那里得到礼物和东西。最著名的是那个叫
the shilling sent to him by the Ottoman Sultan? Well, I mean, let's be honest, he loves bling as well as attention. And the more medals, the more sashes, the more kind of gaudy bits of jewelry that he can attach to his hat, the better. And I do think, so you quoted him right into his father, who is a vicar, who lives in a chilly rectory in Norfolk. It's basically the opposite of celebrating a victory in Naples with a glamorous international celebrity. And I think that that contrast kind of subliminally is working away in Nelson's mind. And of course, in the long run, it will affect his attitude not just to his father and to the place that he grew up, but to his wife, Fanny, who is also in this cold and chilly Norfolk rectory. I think that's dead right.
奥斯曼苏丹送给他的那个“先令”？嗯，我的意思是，让我们诚实一点，他喜欢闪闪发光的东西，也喜欢关注。勋章越多，饰带越多，他能挂在帽子上的那种俗气的珠宝越多越好。我确实认为，所以你引用了他写给他父亲的话，他父亲是一位牧师，住在诺福克郡一个寒冷的牧师住宅里。这基本上与在那不勒斯与一位迷人的国际名人庆祝胜利是相反的。我认为这种对比在潜意识里在纳尔逊的脑海中起作用。当然，从长远来看，这不仅会影响他对他的父亲和他长大的地方的态度，还会影响他对他的妻子范妮的态度，她也住在那个寒冷、阴冷的诺福克牧师住宅里。我认为那是完全正确的。
I think there's a slight sense here. And here, you know, I think Listers can make their own minds up because biographers have done the same. So biographers are perhaps a little bit more critical of Nelson. and of Emma, suggests that at this point there's a kind of dizziness, almost, that his head is ringing anyway when he turns up in the harbour, but slightly begins to be turned. Anyway, clearly the key figures in his relationship with Naples are the Hamilton's. So Sir William Hamilton, it's definitely not the ideal point in Sir William Hamilton's career for Nelson to arrive. So William Hamilton is quite old at this point. There's a sense in which he has
我认为这里有一种轻微的感觉。在这里，你知道，我认为听众可以自己做决定，因为传记作者也做了同样的事情。所以传记作者也许对纳尔逊和艾玛稍微批判一点，暗示在这一点上有一种眩晕，当他出现在港口时，他的头无论如何都在嗡嗡作响，但开始稍微有点被冲昏了。无论如何，显然他与那不勒斯关系中的关键人物是汉密尔顿夫妇。所以威廉·汉密尔顿爵士，这绝对不是威廉·汉密尔顿爵士职业生涯中纳尔逊抵达的理想时机。威廉·汉密尔顿在这一点上相当老了。有一种感觉，他已经
gone native a little bit. So his loyalties are slightly divided between those to Britain and those to the Neapolitan courts, which he is so close. You don't think he would argue that they're indistinguishable, that Naples is the last, you know, I mean, it's the last major power in the Mediterranean allied to Britain. And so therefore it's essential to prop them up. And actually the Admiralty agrees with this. I mean, this is definitely British policy. He would definitely make that case. And there is an element of truth in it. And yet I think if you're any diplomat will tell you, you always have to, you always have to understand that it's a complicated dance, isn't it? Between your superiors in London and the people
有点“本土化”了。所以他的忠诚在某种程度上被分开了，在对英国的忠诚和对那不勒斯宫廷的忠诚之间，他与那不勒斯宫廷如此亲近。你不认为他会争辩说它们是无法区分的，那不勒斯是地中海最后一个，你知道，我的意思是，它是最后一个与英国结盟的地中海大国。因此，支持他们是至关重要的。实际上，海军部也同意这一点。我的意思是，这绝对是英国的政策。他肯定会提出这个论点。而且其中确实有真实的成分。然而，我认为如果你是任何外交官，他们都会告诉你，你总是必须，你总是必须明白这是一场复杂的舞蹈，不是吗？在你在伦敦的上司和那些人之间
that you are, especially if, as in this case, the guy who's the king is an absolute buffoon and his wife has very pronounced vested interest and the cities of Tinderboxes we have already established. And if the king's wife, the queen, is best friends with your own wife, which is the state of play with William and Emma Hamilton, because Emma and the Queen are absolute besties at this point. Exactly, exactly. And I think what's obvious from the very beginning is that for completely understandable reasons, Nelson is besotted with the Hamilton's. I think Nelson has always, and it's not just Emma, it's Sir William as well, I think, because I think Nelson has always been somebody, perhaps because his own father, you know, it's clear that you don't
你所处的，特别是如果，像这种情况下，那个国王是一个绝对的笨蛋，而他的妻子有非常明显的既得利益，而且城市是火药桶，我们已经确定了。如果国王的妻子，王后，是你自己妻子的好朋友，这就是威廉和艾玛·汉密尔顿的情况，因为艾玛和王后在这一点上是绝对的闺蜜。正是如此，正是如此。而且我认为从一开始就很明显，出于完全可以理解的原因，纳尔逊对汉密尔顿夫妇着迷。我认为纳尔逊一直，不仅仅是艾玛，还有威廉爵士，因为我认为纳尔逊一直是一个人，也许是因为他自己的父亲，你知道，很明显你并不
think that highly of the Reverend Nelson. No, I do. I mean, I love it. You know, I love a vicar, but there's a contrast between a vicar in a Chile rectory and a glamorous and faintly cynical aristocrat who collects erotic freezes from buried Roman cities. But Nelson has always craved father figures, hasn't he? He's had them all his life, especially in the Navy, Captain Locker, Admiral Hood, Sir John Jervis. He loves a very self-confident, impressive. older man who takes him under his wing. And he wants that man to love him. And William Hamilton, despite everything that is going to happen, I mean, he is devoted to Nelson, which people find very odd in due course. But his devotion to Nelson, I think, is absolutely genuine. Although he's not as devoted as his wife. That's true. That's true. So Emma Hamilton, as we've said, a celebrity. She is a very, very glamorous and sexy woman. And she's close to age in Nelson. Well, he's 40. She's in her early to mid-30s. And she makes a huge fuss. I mean, she had fallen into his arms in a sort of mock faint or a real faint when he arrived in the harbour. Oh, God, is it possible? Oh, you're alive, all this kind of thing. And then when they install him in their house, the Palazzo Sessa, and she makes a great fuss of him, she tends to,
认为纳尔逊牧师有多高尚。不，我确实。我的意思是，我爱它。你知道，我喜欢牧师，但在一个寒冷的牧师住宅里的牧师和一个迷人且略带愤世嫉俗的、收集被埋葬的罗马城市色情浮雕的贵族之间存在对比。但纳尔逊一直渴望父亲形象，不是吗？他一生中都有他们，特别是在海军中，洛克船长（Captain Locker）、胡德海军上将、约翰·杰维斯爵士（Sir John Jervis）。他喜欢一个非常自信、令人印象深刻的年长男人，他把他置于自己的羽翼之下。他希望那个男人爱他。而威廉·汉密尔顿，尽管将要发生的一切，我的意思是，他致力于纳尔逊，人们在适当的时候会觉得这非常奇怪。但他对纳尔逊的奉献，我认为是绝对真诚的。虽然他没有他的妻子那么投入。那是真的。那是真的。所以艾玛·汉密尔顿，正如我们所说，是一个名人。她是一个非常非常迷人且性感的女人。而且她和纳尔逊年龄相近。嗯，他 40 岁。她 30 多岁出头。她大惊小怪。我的意思是，当他抵达港口时，她以一种模拟昏厥或真实的昏厥倒在他的怀里。哦，天哪，这可能吗？哦，你还活着，所有这些东西。然后当他们把他安置在他们的房子里，塞萨宫（Palazzo Sessa），她对他大惊小怪，她倾向于
his wounds. She cuts up his food because, of course, he's only got one arm. She pours his wine. She tells everybody, look what a great man he is, all of this kind of thing. I think you would, almost anybody would have found that very, very flattering. But if you are somebody like Nelson, who, you know, he's been, first of all, he's been at sea for months with no female company. He loves attention. You know, he always has thought he's a star and he's always had a slight sense, Oh, I haven't had the respect that I deserve. Why would this not go to your head? Of course it goes to his head, I think, a little bit.
照顾他的伤口。她切碎他的食物，因为，当然，他只有一只手臂。她倒他的酒。她告诉每个人，看他是一个多么伟大的人，所有这些东西。我想你会，几乎任何人都会觉得那非常非常令人受宠若惊。但如果你是像纳尔逊这样的人，你知道，他，首先，他在海上待了几个月，没有女性陪伴。他喜欢关注。你知道，他一直认为自己是一个明星，而且他一直有一种轻微的感觉，哦，我没有得到我应得的尊重。为什么这不会冲昏你的头脑？当然它冲昏了他的头脑，我想，一点点。
There's probably no one in Europe better qualified to give him exactly what he wants in terms of adulation. Because Emma, the reason that she's an international star, she has these attitudes, which you think are ludicrous. But I mean, basically, the point of them is that they bring to life classical statuary or freezes or whatever, and people are stunned by it. So Emma is very, very good at bringing to life scenes from kind of antique heroism and giving it a kind of massive histrionic charge. And you cannot imagine anything better suited to Nelson's taste because this is, you know, all his Christmas is coming at once.
欧洲可能没有人比她更有资格在奉承方面给他他想要的东西。因为艾玛，她成为国际明星的原因，她有这些姿态，你认为这很荒谬。但我的意思是，基本上，它们的意义在于它们使古典雕像或浮雕等栩栩如生，人们对此感到震惊。所以艾玛非常非常擅长使古代英雄主义的场景栩栩如生，并赋予它一种巨大的戏剧性冲击。而你无法想象有什么比这更适合纳尔逊的品味了，因为这是，你知道，他所有的圣诞节都同时到来了。
Not only is he being celebrated as a hero, but he's being celebrated as a hero in the most dramatic and up-to-date manner possible by probably the most famous woman in Europe and his cup overfloweth. And not merely that, but actually there is no place in Europe that is better suited to be the backdrop for a kind of theatrical spectacle. And Nelson has always regarded himself to some degree as a character on a stage, you know, maybe playing a classical hero or whatever. And here he is in Naples, in the shadow of his hubius. With this fabulously attractive and famous woman who, so a kind of sample of the way that she addresses him. Joy, joy, joy to you, brave, gallant, immortalized Nelson. Nelson. This is how she talks to him all the time. And it has to be said, this is not how Fanny back in Norfolk is accustomed to address her husband. So I tell you something, Tom. This is actually what Theo, this is how Theo addresses me behind your back.
他不仅被庆祝为英雄，而且他正以最戏剧性和最现代的方式被欧洲最著名的女人庆祝，他的杯子溢出了。不仅如此，实际上欧洲没有比这更适合作为一种戏剧性奇观背景的地方了。而纳尔逊在某种程度上一直把自己视为舞台上的一个角色，你知道，也许扮演一个古典英雄什么的。而他现在在那不勒斯，在维苏威火山的阴影下。与这个极其迷人且著名的女人在一起，所以，她称呼他的一种方式的样本。喜悦，喜悦，喜悦给你，勇敢、英勇、不朽的纳尔逊。纳尔逊。这就是她一直对他说话的方式。而且必须说，这不是范妮在诺福克习惯称呼她丈夫的方式。所以我告诉你一件事，汤姆。这实际上是西奥（Theo）在背后称呼我的方式。
Yeah. Well, I know you were clearly the Emma. I am the fanny. Now, here's the funny thing. I think in some ways, Nelson is oblivious to the possible implications of this, because there is a kind of boyish innocence to him. the proof of that. Do you think? I do because I think he is, he writes to Fanny and he is so tactlessly open about his, yeah, his relationship with the Hamilton's. Yeah, she's great. I've met this girl. She's brilliant. Well, this is the thing. He tells the story about Emma falling into his arms in the harbour. You know, he tells that to Fanny in a letter to Fanny. He says, I cannot wait to introduce you to this woman, Emma Hamilton. She's one of the very best women in the world, how few could have made the turn she has. By the turn, he means the progress, the self-improvement. She's an honour to her sex. A kindness with Sir William to me is more than
是的。嗯，我知道你显然是艾玛。我是范妮。现在，有趣的事情是。我认为在某些方面，纳尔逊对这些可能的含义一无所知，因为他有一种男孩般的纯真。证明这一点。你认为吗？我确实认为，因为我认为他，他写信给范妮，他对他的，是的，他与汉密尔顿夫妇的关系是如此不加掩饰地开放。是的，她很棒。我遇到了这个女孩。她很出色。嗯，这就是重点。他讲述了艾玛在港口倒在他怀里的故事。你知道，他在给范妮的一封信中告诉了范妮。他说：“我迫不及待地想把你介绍给这个女人，艾玛·汉密尔顿。她是世界上最好的女人之一，很少有人能像她那样进步。”通过进步，他指的是进步，自我提升。她是她性别的荣誉。与威廉爵士对我的善意比
I can express. Now, I think if you're planning to have an affair with somebody, I completely agree. You don't write that to your wife. I completely, at this point, absolutely he isn't. But I mean, Nelson is not an innocent. I mean, he's been conducting an affair with a woman in Livorno up in the north of Italy for four years. Yeah, but you can be a man of flesh and blood and yet have this slight, you cannot sense what's coming. I don't think he senses what's going. Yeah, I mean, I think at this point, the appeal of Emma is that she is saying he's brilliant. Yes. You know, she's just going on and on about how wonderful you are. You're a hero and all of that. That's the focus. But I wouldn't say that, you know, oh, he's kind of innocent. You know, he is at this point to reiterate
我能表达的还要多。现在，我认为如果你计划和某人有外遇，我完全同意。你不会那样写给你妻子的。我完全，在这一点上，绝对他不是。但我的意思是，纳尔逊不是一个纯真的人。我的意思是，他已经在意大利北部的利沃诺与一个女人保持了四年的外遇。是的，但你可以是一个有血有肉的人，却有这种轻微的，你无法感觉到即将发生的事情。我不认为他感觉到了正在发生的事情。是的，我的意思是，我认为在这一点上，艾玛的吸引力在于她在说他很出色。是的。你知道，她只是不停地谈论你有多棒。你是一个英雄，所有这些。那是重点。但我不会说，你知道，哦，他有点纯真。你知道，他现在要重申的是
having an affair. But he is more innocent than he might be, I would say. I don't think he has any agenda here. So anyway, there's the issue, obviously, his wife Fannie when she gets these letters is not, she's not exactly over the moon. But there's also a kind of political dimension to this, because as we've said, Sir William and Emma are incredibly close to the royal couple. And that means that Nelson, who has always been a massive sucker for royalty, because listeners will remember in the previous series, he massively sucked up to the future William IV, who was a very boarish bloke in a way that did not endear him to his superiors of the admiralty. And I think that's another point of correspondence with Emma, who's kind of very much the
有外遇。但我认为他比别人可能认为的要单纯得多。我不认为他在这里有什么不可告人的目的。总之，问题显而易见，他的妻子范妮在收到这些信件时，并不怎么高兴。但这其中还有一种政治层面，因为正如我们所说，威廉爵士和艾玛与这对皇室夫妇关系极其亲密。这意味着纳尔逊，他一直是个极其崇拜皇室的人，因为听众们会记得在上一季中，他极力讨好未来的威廉四世，那家伙是个非常粗鲁的人，这种行为并没有让他受到海军部上司的喜爱。我认为这与艾玛有某种对应之处，她非常像是一个
working class Tory, you know, loves a king and a queen, especially a queen. And Nelson obviously, instinctively, that those are his politics as well, I think. Yeah, I think so. So what that means is that when he gets wind of a Neapolitan plan, a new sort of departure in the war, he is perhaps not as skeptical as he might otherwise have been. So this plan comes really from Maria Carolina. Remember, she hates the French. Now that the Neapolotans have heard the news of the defeat of Napoleon's fleet in Egypt,
工人阶级的托利党人，你知道，热爱国王和王后，尤其是王后。我认为纳尔逊显然本能地也是这种政治立场。是的，我想也是。所以这意味着，当他听到那不勒斯的计划，即战争中一种新的动向时，他可能不像平时那样怀疑。这个计划实际上来自玛丽亚·卡罗琳娜。记住，她痛恨法国人。现在那不勒斯人听到了拿破仑舰队在埃及战败的消息，
they say, gosh, couldn't we launch a counterattack against the French in Italy? Basically, what Maria Carolina wants to do is to send Naples' army north to drive the French out of Rome, which they'd captured in, what is it, February, I think it was. and then push on into Tuscany. And if they can get into Tuscany, then her family in Austria, the Hapsburgs, may well look at this. This is what she's hoping, and rejoin the war. And that will allow them to avenge Marie Antoinette together.
他们说，天哪，我们难道不能对意大利的法国人发动反击吗？基本上，玛丽亚·卡罗琳娜想做的是把那不勒斯的军队派往北方，将法国人赶出罗马，他们在二月份（我想是二月）占领了那里。然后继续推进到托斯卡纳。如果他们能进入托斯卡纳，那么她在奥地利的家族，哈布斯堡王朝，很可能会关注这一点。这是她所希望的，并重新加入战争。这将使他们能够共同为玛丽·安托瓦内特复仇。
I mean, I think this is the great gamble that Nelson takes, really, isn't it? Is that he has to weigh up, will Austria come into the war? Yeah. And I think it's not mad to think that they would because, you know, Mary Carolina is herself Austrian. The Austrian royal family have every reason to hate the French. And the prospect of crushing the French between the two flanks. I mean, this is what Nelson loves to do.
我的意思是，我认为这是纳尔逊所做的巨大赌博，不是吗？他必须权衡，奥地利会加入战争吗？是的。我认为认为他们会加入并不疯狂，因为你知道，玛丽亚·卡罗琳娜本人就是奥地利人。奥地利皇室有充分的理由痛恨法国人。而且在两翼夹击法国人的前景。我的意思是，这正是纳尔逊喜欢做的事情。
It's basically what he'd done at the Battle of the Nile. So you can see why it would appeal to him. The one thing I will say, though, about Nelson, though, Tom, is that Nelson at sea is unbeatable. Nelson on land is always a fiasco. Nelson is a very poor judge of military, stuff on land. And the issue is also Naples has no real military tradition. It has no history of winning land battles. But it does have an Austrian general, doesn't it? It does. And it has an
这基本上就是他在尼罗河海战中所做的事情。所以你可以看出为什么这会吸引他。不过，关于纳尔逊，我有一点要说，汤姆，那就是纳尔逊在海上是不可战胜的。纳尔逊在陆地上总是一场闹剧。纳尔逊对陆地军事事务的判断力非常差。而且问题还在于那不勒斯没有真正的军事传统。它没有赢得陆战的历史。但它确实有一位奥地利将军，不是吗？是的。而且它有一个
excellent history of exciting, colourful military uniforms. But as we discovered in our series about the First World War, the more colourful the uniform, usually the worst the army. Anyway, there's a couple of other things. So kicking the French out of Italy has long been a British, a really important British war aim. So you could see why he likes that. He wants to please the Hamilton's. He wants to please the King and Queen. And he has new orders from London. And the new orders from London, this reinforces something you were saying earlier. He must give the most cordial and unlimited protection to the King and Queen of Naples. And on a quote, most carefully avoid giving them the smallest cause for suspicion, jealousy or offence. And the irony of this is,
极好的历史，拥有令人兴奋、色彩鲜艳的军服。但正如我们在关于第一次世界大战的系列节目中发现的那样，军服越鲜艳，军队通常就越糟糕。总之，还有几件事。所以把法国人赶出意大利长期以来一直是英国的一个非常重要的战争目标。所以你可以看出为什么他喜欢这一点。他想取悦汉密尔顿夫妇。他想取悦国王和王后。而且他有来自伦敦的新命令。来自伦敦的新命令加强了你刚才所说的一些内容。他必须给予那不勒斯国王和王后最亲切和无限的保护。并且引用原文，最小心地避免给他们造成哪怕最小的怀疑、嫉妒或冒犯。而讽刺的是，
the Admiralty have sent him these orders because they think Nelson can be proud and tactless and that he might offend the Neapolitan monarchy. What they don't realize is that he will go to the completely, the opposite extreme and he will align himself completely with them. Well, it's a reminder of just how far Nelson is from London and it takes a long time for messages to travel from, say, Naples back to Britain and vice versa. So Nelson really is on his own here. And as you said, when it comes to geopolitics and land wars, he is much less confident than he is at sea. On the naval campaign, there is one further issue, which is that Malta is occupied by the French and Nelson is conducting a blockade of Malta because he can see that strategically that will be key as well. Because if they can roll the French out of Italy and secure Malta, then that will absolutely set Britain's Mastery of the Mediterranean.
海军部给他发这些命令是因为他们认为纳尔逊可能会傲慢且缺乏机智，他可能会冒犯那不勒斯君主。他们没有意识到的是，他会走向完全相反的极端，他会完全与他们结盟。好吧，这提醒了我们纳尔逊离伦敦有多远，消息从那不勒斯传回英国，反之亦然，需要很长时间。所以纳尔逊在这里真的是孤军奋战。正如你所说，当谈到地缘政治和陆战时，他比在海上时自信心要少得多。在海军战役方面，还有一个问题，那就是马耳他被法国人占领，纳尔逊正在对马耳他进行封锁，因为他可以看出从战略上讲这也是关键。因为如果他们能把法国人赶出意大利并确保马耳他，那么这将绝对奠定英国在地中海的霸权。
on very, very solid foundations. The upshot of this is that Sir William Hamilton, Emma Hamilton are super keen on this expedition. Nelson is very keen on it. Yes, this is the time to strike. Let's do this. So by early October 1798, the preparations are in full swing. The Austrians have sent them a general to command the army, who is General Mac. They have mustered more than 30,000 men in very fancy new uniforms.
建立在非常非常坚实的基础之上。其结果是，威廉·汉密尔顿爵士和艾玛·汉密尔顿对这次远征超级热心。纳尔逊也非常热心。是的，现在是出击的时候了。让我们这样做吧。因此，到1798年10月初，准备工作正如火如荼地进行。奥地利人派了一位将军来指挥军队，那就是马克将军。他们召集了超过3万名穿着非常华丽新军装的士兵。
There's a great scene when Maria Carolina like kind of Elizabeth at Tilbury rides out to inspire them. She's all dressed up as well. Nelson thinks he's great. Oh, yeah. He writes to Fannie and says, oh, she is a great king. And he also writes to London and says, these are the finest troops in Europe. So we will see. So in fact, a lot of these people, by the way, they're peasants from the Italian countryside who've actually never held a musket before.
有一个很棒的场景，玛丽亚·卡罗琳娜就像蒂尔伯里的伊丽莎白一样骑马出去激励他们。她也盛装打扮。纳尔逊认为她很棒。哦，是的。他写信给范妮说，哦，她是一位伟大的国王。他还写信给伦敦说，这是欧洲最精锐的部队。所以我们将拭目以待。事实上，顺便说一句，这些人中有很多是来自意大利乡村的农民，他们实际上以前从未拿过火枪。
So we'll see how that works out for them. Anyway, on the 22nd of November, in driving rain, this army marches out of Naples on the road that leads north and ahead is Rome and ahead is the most controversial episode of Nelson's life. Brilliant. What a cliffhanger. And we will find out whether the Neapolitan forces sweep the French back into France or whether they don't after the break. This episode is brought to you by Peloton. A new era of fitness is here. the new Peloton cross-training tread plus, powered by Peloton IQ, built for breakthroughs with personalized workout plans, real-time insights, and endless ways to move. Lift with confidence, while Peloton IQ counts reps, corrects form, and tracks your progress. Let yourself run, lift, flow, and go. Explore the new Peloton cross-training tread plus at Onepeloton.ca.
所以我们将看看这对他们来说结果如何。总之，11月22日，在倾盆大雨中，这支军队在通往北方的道路上离开了那不勒斯，前方是罗马，前方是纳尔逊一生中最具争议的事件。太棒了。真是个悬念。休息过后，我们将找出那不勒斯军队是将法国人扫回法国，还是没有。本集由Peloton赞助播出。健身的新时代已经到来。全新的Peloton交叉训练Tread Plus，由Peloton IQ驱动，为突破而生，提供个性化的锻炼计划、实时见解和无穷的运动方式。自信地进行举重，同时Peloton IQ计算次数、纠正姿势并跟踪您的进度。让自己奔跑、举重、流动并前进。在Onepeloton.ca探索全新的Peloton交叉训练Tread Plus。
TD Bank knows that running a small business is a journey, from startup to growing, and managing your business. That's why they have a dedicated small business advice hub on their website to provide tips and insights on business banking to entrepreneurs. No matter the stage of business you're in, visit TD.com slash small business advice to find out more or to match with a TD small business banking account manager. This episode is brought to you by Vanguard. Now, Thrillingly, this name Vanguard was inspired by HMS Vanguard, the flagship of none other than Admiral Nelson. He pursues the French to Abacier Bay on the shores of Egypt for the Battle of the Nile and save the world from Napoleon, really. So great scenes. So tremendous record
道明银行知道经营一家小企业是一段旅程，从创业到成长，再到管理您的业务。这就是为什么他们在网站上设有专门的小企业建议中心，为企业家提供有关商业银行的提示和见解。无论您处于业务的哪个阶段，请访问TD.com/small-business-advice了解更多信息，或与道明小企业银行客户经理匹配。本集由先锋集团赞助播出。令人激动的是，这个名字“先锋”的灵感来自于先锋号战舰，即纳尔逊海军上将的旗舰。他为了尼罗河海战在埃及海岸追击法国人到阿布基尔湾，并真正从拿破仑手中拯救了世界。所以场景很棒。所以记录非常辉煌
there from Vanguard, a ship that certainly saw no lack of action. Yes. Now, speaking of action, if you want to put your financial plans into action, but you've been putting off sorting out your ISA. Or, if you're new to investing and you don't know where to start, Vanguard offers a range of ISA options, including their managed ISA, which could be a great fit. So essentially, it's stocks and shares ISA, but it is managed by the experts of Vanguard. They'll help you to work out your risk appetite, match you to an investment plan that is right for you, and then they will do the rest. Search Vanguard to find out more when investing your capital is at risk.
来自先锋号，这艘船确实不乏行动。是的。说到行动，如果您想将您的财务计划付诸行动，但一直推迟整理您的ISA。或者，如果您是投资新手，不知道从哪里开始，先锋集团提供一系列ISA选项，包括他们的管理型ISA，这可能非常适合您。所以本质上，它是股票和股份ISA，但由先锋集团的专家管理。他们将帮助您确定您的风险偏好，为您匹配适合您的投资计划，然后他们将完成其余的工作。搜索先锋集团以了解更多信息，投资资本有风险。
Tax rules apply. Hello, welcome back to The Restless History, and it is November 1798. The Army of Naples, in their splendid uniforms, have marched north to Rome, that they've been encouraged by Nelson, by his new pals, the Hamilton's. And the way we set it up, Dominic, before the break, people might think it's going to be a complete fiasco. But actually, initially it isn't. So they trudged through the rain, trudged through the mud, they reach the outskirts of Rome,
适用税收规则。你好，欢迎回到《不安的历史》，现在是1798年11月。那不勒斯军队穿着华丽的制服，向北进军罗马，他们受到了纳尔逊和他的新伙伴汉密尔顿夫妇的鼓励。多米尼克，我们在休息前设定的方式，人们可能认为这会是一场彻底的闹剧。但实际上，最初并不是这样。所以他们冒着雨，在泥泞中跋涉，到达了罗马郊区，
and they find that the French have basically melted away. They're nowhere to be seen. And so on the 29th of November, absolute scenes. King Ferdinand, this boorish oaf, who basically all he can interest in is making footmen eat frogs and going hunting. He rides into Rome in triumph, and he's saluted across Europe as, you know, the new Caesar. So the British ambassador in Russia
他们发现法国人基本上已经消失了。他们无处可寻。因此，在11月29日，出现了绝对的场景。费迪南德国王，这个粗鲁的笨蛋，他基本上只对让仆人吃青蛙和去打猎感兴趣。他凯旋进入罗马，被全欧洲誉为，你知道，新的凯撒。所以英国驻俄罗斯大使
describes him as manly and vigorous which I don't think he's ever been described as before and he has a week to celebrate and then on the 7th of December Oh dear, France declares war on Naples and what happens then? Yeah, nothing good, unfortunately. So the very next day,
形容他充满男子气概和活力，我想他以前从未被这样形容过，他有一周的时间来庆祝，然后在12月7日，哦天哪，法国向那不勒斯宣战，然后发生了什么？是的，不幸的是，没有好事。所以就在第二天，
King Ferdinand, who's been celebrating, here's the news that a French army is marching on Rome and of course they have been waiting thinking, well, maybe the Austrians will pile in. But the Austrians don't do they? the Austrians completely let them down. I think it's harsh to blame the Austrians for this. I mean, I don't think we, I think the finger of blame points very squarely at King
一直在庆祝的费迪南德国王听到了法国军队正在向罗马进军的消息，当然他们一直在等待，心想，也许奥地利人会加入。但奥地利人没有，不是吗？奥地利人完全让他们失望了。我认为把这归咎于奥地利人是苛刻的。我的意思是，我不认为我们，我认为指责的矛头非常直接地指向国王
Verdinand and the Neapulton army. Because the first thing he does when he hears news that the French are coming, he immediately summons his carriage, leaps into his carriage. I'm out of here. Yeah, let's go back to Naples. And Naples, great banter, people said, he came, he saw, he fled, which is basically exactly what he did. Now, as for the Neapolitan Army, the finest troops in Europe, according to Horatio Nelson,
费迪南德和那不勒斯军队。因为当他听到法国人要来的消息时，他做的第一件事就是立即召集他的马车，跳进他的马车。我离开这里。是的，让我们回到那不勒斯。在那不勒斯，人们开玩笑说，他来了，他看见了，他逃跑了，这正是他所做的。现在，至于那不勒斯军队，根据霍雷肖·纳尔逊的说法，这是欧洲最精锐的部队，
they collapse within hours, some units within minutes. Yeah. Well, you know what Nelson said in the wake of this collapse? He'd been bigging them up before. Now he says, the Neapolitan officers have not lost much honour, for God knows they had but little to lose. God, he's changed. Yeah, hasn't he? Yeah, because a lot of them didn't even fire a shot.
他们在几小时内就崩溃了，有些部队在几分钟内就崩溃了。是的。好吧，你知道纳尔逊在这次崩溃后说了什么吗？他之前一直在吹捧他们。现在他说，那不勒斯军官们并没有失去多少荣誉，因为上帝知道他们本来就没什么可失去的。天哪，他变了。是的，不是吗？是的，因为他们中的许多人甚至没有开一枪。
They ran away straight away. They left all their artillery behind. They left them guns behind. they left their baggage behind. I mean, the French claim this is a great military victory, but to be honest, they're not really fighting anybody because they've all run away. I'm not criticising them.
他们立刻逃跑了。他们留下了所有的炮兵。他们留下了枪支。他们留下了行李。我的意思是，法国人声称这是一场伟大的军事胜利，但老实说，他们并没有真正与任何人战斗，因为他们都逃跑了。我不是在批评他们。
I'd run away as well. Right. Well, okay. So in the next two weeks, the French just keep coming, obviously. They retake Rome. They continue south. So we get to Christmas 1798. Christmas is coming,
我也会逃跑的。好吧。那么在接下来的两周里，法国人显然一直在前进。他们夺回了罗马。他们继续向南。所以我们到了1798年的圣诞节。圣诞节快到了，
and the French are basically marching now on Naples. Now, we described Naples as a Tinderbox. And the match or whatever it is, the bit that is struck has been struck even though it's raining right exactly so Naples is now
法国人基本上现在正在向那不勒斯进军。现在，我们将那不勒斯描述为一个火药桶。而火柴或任何东西，被点燃的那一点已经被点燃了，尽管正在下雨，完全正确，所以那不勒斯现在是
I mean it was pretty chaotic before it's now an absolute utter unbridled chaos the city is crowded with refugees the local kind of do gooders the bien pancant the enlightened liberal metropolitan elite
我的意思是，之前就已经很混乱了，现在是绝对彻底的、无拘无束的混乱，城市里挤满了难民，当地的所谓好心人，那些开明的自由派大都市精英，
the Jacobin they're called the Jacobin they're coca hoop and Maria Carolina I mean if you're the sister of Mariantoinette, you kind of know how this ends, right? So they're holed up in the Royal Palace at Capo de Monti, Ferdinand and Mirro, Carolina, he's, you know, gone rampaging around with his chamber pots, like in a massive state.
雅各宾派，他们被称为雅各宾派，他们非常兴奋，而玛丽亚·卡罗琳娜，我的意思是，如果你是玛丽·安托瓦内特的妹妹，你大概知道结局会怎样，对吧？所以他们躲在卡波迪蒙特的皇宫里，费迪南德和玛丽亚·卡罗琳娜，他，你知道，带着他的便壶到处乱窜，处于一种巨大的状态。
She with her husky voice is kind of taken refuge. Oh, no. I've got to have my head chopped off. Yeah, under the bed, like thinking that she's going to turn out like Mary Antoinette. Outside in the streets, there are kind of rival gangs and mobs fighting. There's the pillaging and burning has already started. It's a real kind of end of the world kind of scene. And the climax comes, I mean, this is, why is there no great film of this?
她用她沙哑的声音躲了起来。哦，不。我得被砍头了。是的，躲在床底下，以为自己会像玛丽·安托瓦内特一样。在街上，有各种敌对的帮派和暴徒在打架。掠夺和焚烧已经开始了。这真是一种世界末日的场景。高潮来了，我的意思是，为什么没有关于这个的伟大电影？
The climax comes on Christmas Eve. The king and queen arranged this lavish banquets, but this has been done to distract people. It's a cover, because actually they've decided that they will flee to the second capital of the kingdom and the two Sicily, which is in the real. Sicily, which is Palermo. That's confusing, isn't it? The thing is, they don't trust their own ships to take them because there've been rumours. They've heard reports that Republican ideas have been sweeping through the cruise.
高潮出现在平安夜。国王和王后安排了这些奢华的宴会，但这只是为了分散人们的注意力。这是一个掩护，因为实际上他们已经决定逃往两西西里王国的第二个首都，也就是真正的西西里，即巴勒莫。这很令人困惑，不是吗？问题是，他们不信任自己的船只带他们走，因为有传言。他们听说共和思想已经在船员中蔓延的报道。
None of that nonsense in the Royal Navy. Not at all. The person they want to take them is Horatio Nelson. Now, remember, not only is he close to them because of the Hamilton's, he's close to them because he's been told by the Admiralty, do not, under any circumstances, let them down at all. So he says, fine, I'll take you, and I'll take as much of the royal treasure as you can carry. And so as night falls on Christmas Eve, they kind of scuttle down to the harbour with their bodyguards.
皇家海军中没有那种废话。一点也没有。他们想要带他们走的人是霍雷肖·纳尔逊。现在，记住，他不仅因为汉密尔顿夫妇而与他们关系密切，他还因为海军部告诉他，无论如何都不要让他们失望，而与他们关系密切。所以他说，好吧，我会带你们走，我会带走你们能携带的所有皇家宝藏。所以当平安夜夜幕降临时，他们带着保镖溜到了港口。
Emma Hamilton comes with them. She's in charge of escorting the royal treasure. And Sir William Hamilton is kind of his vases. Erotic vases and whatever. And the boats that are sent to pick him up are commanded by somebody who will be featuring later in this series. who is Nelson's flag captain, so on board the vanguard, a man called Thomas Hardy. An enormous man, isn't he, Hardy? An enormous kind of balding man.
艾玛·汉密尔顿和他们一起去了。她负责护送皇家宝藏。而威廉·汉密尔顿爵士带着他的花瓶。色情花瓶之类的。而派去接他的船只由本系列后面会出现的人指挥。他是纳尔逊的旗舰船长，在先锋号上，一个叫托马斯·哈迪的人。哈迪是个身材魁梧的人，不是吗？一个身材魁梧、有点秃顶的人。
He likes flocking people. Well, he does, and we'll come to this. So he takes them all back, and the king and queen take Nelson's cabin on board the vanguard, and the Hamilton's take Hardys, and off the ship glides into the darkness. And as they go, they can see flames rising from the shore behind them, And it's not coming from Mount Vesuvius. It's coming from the city that is increasingly a blaze. It's like the scene from, if people are familiar with the Godfather part two, there's a scene when Al Pacino has to flee Cuba in the Cuban Revolution. And it's this
他喜欢成群结队的人。好吧，他确实喜欢，我们稍后会谈到这一点。于是他把他们都带了回来，国王和王后登上了先锋号，住进了纳尔逊的船舱，汉密尔顿夫妇则住进了哈迪的船舱，船就这样滑入了黑暗之中。当他们离开时，可以看到身后的岸上火光冲天，那不是来自维苏威火山，而是来自那座正逐渐陷入火海的城市。这就像《教父2》里的场景，当阿尔·帕西诺在古巴革命中不得不逃离古巴时，也有类似的一幕。这是一种
similar sort of atmosphere, kind of the streets full of people, the sense of panic and whatnot. Anyway, things don't get any better for them, do they? Because the next day, Christmas Day, they're in the Bay of Naples, and there's a colossal storm. Now, course Nelson is used to storms, but his passengers are not. So William Hamilton says, so I'm not going to drown. And he retires to his cabin with a loaded pistol and says, I'll blow up my brains rather than kind of sink to the deep. Isn't there one of the ambassadors who's going with them? He has a kind of erotic portrait of his mistress. And he's so worried that he'll drown and go to meet his maker that he throws it overboard, much of his later regret. That's a, that's a very poor choice
类似的氛围，街道上挤满了人，充满了恐慌等等。总之，他们的处境并没有好转，对吧？因为第二天，也就是圣诞节，他们停泊在那不勒斯湾，遭遇了一场巨大的风暴。当然，纳尔逊习惯了风暴，但他的乘客们却不习惯。威廉·汉密尔顿说，我可不想淹死。于是他退回到自己的船舱，拿着一把装满子弹的手枪说，我宁愿自杀也不愿沉入深渊。随行的外交官中不是有一个人吗？他有一张情妇的色情肖像画。他太担心自己会淹死并去见上帝，于是把它扔进了海里，后来后悔不已。那是一个，那是一个非常糟糕的选择
of action in a storm. Now, the other thing is the royal couple have their youngest son, Prince Carlo Albert, is nine years old, and he's terrified by the storm. And this is a terrible story, actually. He goes into a fit, doesn't he? A kind of convulsive fit that goes on for hours. And he dies in Emma Hamilton's arms.
在风暴中的行动。还有一件事，皇室夫妇最小的儿子，卡洛·阿尔贝托王子，才九岁，他被风暴吓坏了。这其实是一个可怕的故事。他发作了，不是吗？一种持续了几个小时的抽搐发作。他在艾玛·汉密尔顿的怀里去世了。
So she's trying to comfort him because she's so close to the family. And she's regarded, I'm not always the most pro-Emma. commentator, but she is regarded as having behaved very well. She doesn't lose her composure. She behaves absolutely splendidly. Shall I quote Kate Williams? Refusing to let the experience of being sick, defeat her, or to droop under the atmosphere of panic, she tried to comfort peevish courtiers who had never known hardship and struggled to keep some kind of order in the rolling ship. And I think you do get there a glimpse of what Nelson at Mars about her. You know, she is a woman for a crisis. She has spirit, Tom. She has been. She has been.
所以她试图安慰他，因为她和王室关系非常亲密。她被认为——我并不总是最支持艾玛的评论员——但她确实被认为表现得非常好。她没有失去镇定。她表现得非常出色。我引用凯特·威廉姆斯的话好吗？她拒绝让生病的经历打败自己，也没有在恐慌的气氛中萎靡不振，她试图安慰那些从未经历过苦难、脾气暴躁的朝臣，并努力在摇晃的船上维持某种秩序。我想你从中可以看出纳尔逊为什么那么迷恋她。你知道，她是一个能应对危机的女人。她有精神，汤姆。她有，她有。
balls. She has spunk, doesn't she? She does. She absolutely does. Right. So, they survive. They endure the storm. The next day through the rain, they see Palermo. The kind of domes and the churches and the Palazzi and whatnot. Now, if Naples was sort of glamorous, exotic, a little bit dilapidated, Palermo is all these things on steroids. So even as they disembark, there's these huge crowds of beggars and whatnot. And here in Palermo, they will stay for the next five months. And they're kind of secure, aren't they? Because as long as the Royal Navy maintains command of the seas, the French can't get to Sicily. Exactly. So it is kind of a flight from Varenne, you know, which Louis XVIth and Marie Antoinette attempted and were foiled. The Neapolitan
胆量。她很有勇气，不是吗？她确实有。她绝对有。好吧。所以，他们幸存了下来。他们忍受了风暴。第二天，透过雨幕，他们看到了巴勒莫。那些圆顶、教堂、宫殿等等。如果说那不勒斯是那种迷人、异国情调、有点破旧的地方，那么巴勒莫就是这些东西的加强版。所以即使在他们下船时，也有大批的乞丐等等。在巴勒莫，他们将停留接下来的五个月。他们算是安全了，对吧？因为只要皇家海军保持对海洋的控制，法国人就无法到达西西里岛。没错。所以这有点像路易十六和玛丽·安托瓦内特试图逃往瓦雷纳却失败的那种逃亡。那不勒斯的
royals, they get away. And in fact, what subsequently happens may give us perhaps a flavorer of what might have happened in France had the flight to Varenne continued, and the king and queen got away. Well, we'll come back to what happens in Naples, because that's very colourful. But let's just look at Nelson. So Nelson and the Hamilton's move in together into a Palermo Palace called the Palazzo Palagonia. And it has erotic freezes all over the ceilings, showing Zeus getting up to his business. Of course it does.
皇室成员，他们逃脱了。事实上，随后发生的事情或许能让我们体会到，如果逃往瓦雷纳的计划继续下去，国王和王后成功逃脱，法国可能会发生什么。好吧，我们稍后再谈那不勒斯发生的事情，因为那非常精彩。但让我们先看看纳尔逊。纳尔逊和汉密尔顿夫妇一起搬进了巴勒莫的一座宫殿，叫帕拉戈尼亚宫。天花板上到处都是色情壁画，描绘着宙斯在做他的那些事。当然会有。
So Nelson is, I mean, this will be the, I mean, we're going to say this sentence about 400 times in this series. Nelson is absolutely shattered. He is mentally and physically exhausted. His letters home are full of complaints, basically about his poor mental health. And his bowels. Yeah. He's not a well man. Yeah, so his mind and his bowels are both shot. There's a sort of sense, I think, when you sort of read the Nelson biographies, whether John Sugden and Roger Knight and whatnot, I think there's a sense that Nelson is, you know, is he depressed? Is he suffering from PTSD? I mean, maybe this is trying to impose
所以纳尔逊，我是说，在这个系列中我们要说这句话大约400次。纳尔逊彻底崩溃了。他在精神和身体上都精疲力竭。他写回家的信里基本上全是关于他糟糕的精神状态的抱怨。还有他的肠胃。是的。他不是个健康的人。是的，所以他的精神和肠胃都垮了。我想当你阅读纳尔逊的传记时，无论是约翰·萨格登还是罗杰·奈特等人的作品，都会有一种感觉，纳尔逊，你知道，他抑郁了吗？他患有创伤后应激障碍吗？我是说，也许这是试图强加
modern labels onto, you know, somebody in the past, which is a bad idea. But when you look at his letters, he writes to a friend of his called Lady Parker. You who remember me always laughing and gay would hardly believe the change, but who can see what I have and be well in health? And then to Fanny, my health is tolerable, but my mind is full of sorrow, not for myself, for I care not, but for my country and the world. And obviously, it's been a terrible embarrassment and disappointment to him that the Neapolitan army has behaved so badly, and they've had to scuttle back to Palermo.
现代标签给过去的人，这是一个坏主意。但当你查看他的信件时，他写给一位叫帕克夫人的朋友：你记得我总是欢笑和快乐，现在很难相信这种变化，但谁能看到我所经历的一切还能保持健康呢？然后写给范妮：我的健康尚可，但我的内心充满了悲伤，不是为我自己，因为我不在乎，而是为了我的国家和世界。显然，那不勒斯军队表现得如此糟糕，他们不得不狼狈逃回巴勒莫，这对他来说是一个巨大的尴尬和失望。
But also the fact I think that it comes so soon after the Battle of the Nile, his great triumph, he's sort of, if you were to plot his mental state on a graph, it'd be all over the place up and down. Well, I think also he feels isolated and alone. He's a long way from London, and he's acting commander-in-chief in the Mediterranean. And there are all these terrible decisions he has to make without really anyone to advise him. Well, you say without really anyone.
但我也认为，这发生在他伟大的胜利——尼罗河海战之后不久，如果把他的精神状态画在图表上，那将是起伏不定的。嗯，我也认为他感到孤立无援。他离伦敦很远，而且是地中海地区的代理总司令。他必须做出所有这些可怕的决定，却没有人真正能为他出谋划策。嗯，你说没有人。
Well, he does, of course. There are the Hamilton's. And it's probably around now, say the first months of 1799, that he finds in Emma an increasing source, not just of advice, but of comfort. Comfort. And what I think gives the game away. is that he starts buying her props for her attitudes. That is such a bad sign, I have to say. And it's not long before both of them are kind of mooning over one another,
嗯，他当然有。有汉密尔顿夫妇。大概就在现在，也就是1799年的头几个月，他发现艾玛不仅是建议的来源，更是安慰的来源。安慰。我认为泄露秘密的是，他开始为她的“姿态”购买道具。我不得不说，这是一个非常糟糕的信号。没过多久，他们两人就开始互相迷恋，
giving each other pet names. You do it. No, you do it. No, you do it. All that kind of stuff. Oh, God. And there's obviously kind of a very intense physical attraction. But I do think also, we've touched on this before,
互相起昵称。你来。不，你来。不，你来。诸如此类的事情。哦，天哪。显然有一种非常强烈的身体吸引力。但我确实也认为，我们之前提到过，
they are very similar personalities. They're both very charismatic. They're both very famous. They're both very histrionic. They're both very prone to depression. But they are also very determined, bold, aggressive, I think, in their kind of instincts. And you can see why they get on. And above all, the reason that Nelson thinks Emma is brilliant is that Emma thinks Nelson
他们的性格非常相似。他们都非常有魅力。他们都非常出名。他们都非常戏剧化。他们都非常容易抑郁。但他们也非常坚定、大胆、激进，我认为，在他们的直觉方面。你可以看出他们为什么合得来。最重要的是，纳尔逊认为艾玛很棒的原因是艾玛认为纳尔逊
is brilliant. So she's, you know, you said how Nelson's disappointed that he, he, he isn't made a Viscount. So she writes to him and says, if I was King of England, I would make you the most noble puissant, Duke Nelson, Marquis Nile, Earl Alexander,
很棒。所以，你知道，你说过纳尔逊对他没有被封为子爵感到失望。于是她写信给他，说：如果我是英国国王，我会让你成为最高贵、最强大的纳尔逊公爵、尼罗河侯爵、亚历山大伯爵、
Viscount Pyramid, Baron Crocodile, and Prince Victory, that posterity might have you in all forms. You could see why this would appeal to someone who is always hungry for recognition and praise. I think there are a couple of things. I think one of them is they both crave attention
金字塔子爵、鳄鱼男爵和胜利亲王，让后世以各种形式铭记你。你可以看出为什么这会吸引一个总是渴望认可和赞美的人。我认为有几件事。我认为其中之一是他们都渴望关注
and they crave attention from other talented and driven people. So I think that's part of it. They feed that. I think both of them feed in each other something else, which you might say is a little bit darker, which is a sense, oh, the world is against me. And Nelson has always had a strain of self-pity, hasn't he? There's always been a side of him that falls out with superiors at the Admiralty or
他们渴望来自其他有才华和有动力的人的关注。所以我认为这是其中的一部分。他们滋养了这一点。我认为他们两人都在对方身上滋养了另一件事，你可能会说这有点阴暗，那就是一种“哦，全世界都在与我作对”的感觉。纳尔逊一直有一种自怜的倾向，不是吗？他总有一面会与海军部的上级闹翻，或者
whatever because he thinks he isn't getting his due. And Emma, I think, is the kind of partner. Yeah, there's the kind of partner who says to you, now come on, put this into perspective, you know, calm down. You're brilliant. But she is the kind of partner who says, you're totally right. They should be festooning you with honours.
无论什么，因为他认为自己没有得到应有的待遇。而艾玛，我认为，是那种会告诉你，“来吧，把这事看开点，你知道，冷静点。你很棒”的伴侣。但她是那种会说，“你完全正确。他们应该用荣誉把你装饰起来”的伴侣。
They, you know, all of this. And she will always, always do that to him and him to her. And they both love it. It's what they want more than anything, I would say. And she, of course, has had a very hard life. I mean, you know, hard beyond Nelson's wildest dreams. And again, I think he respects what she's made of herself. Well, he mentioned the turn, didn't he, the turn she's made in his letter to Fanny.
他们，你知道，所有这些。她总是，总是会对他那样做，他也对她那样做。他们都喜欢这样。我会说，这是他们最想要的东西。当然，她经历过非常艰难的生活。我是说，你知道，艰难到超出了纳尔逊最狂野的梦想。同样，我认为他尊重她所成就的自己。嗯，他在给范妮的信中提到了她所做的转变，不是吗？
So quite early on, there are rumours and whispers in the fleet. So on the 16th of January, so they'd only been in Palermo for, what, three weeks? Another British captain called George Hope left Palermo on the Alk many, and he went to Gibraltar. And when he got to Gibraltar, he said to other officers, Nelson is idling in Palermo and making himself ridiculous with Lady Hamilton. Now, at about the same time, a slightly baleful figure in Nelson's life, Admiral Lord Keith, who is an absolutely textbook casting agency, do formidable Scotsman.
所以很早的时候，舰队里就有流言蜚语。1月16日，他们到巴勒莫才三周？另一位英国船长乔治·霍普乘坐“阿尔克曼号”离开了巴勒莫，前往直布罗陀。当他到达直布罗陀时，他对其他军官说：纳尔逊在巴勒莫无所事事，和汉密尔顿夫人一起让自己变得荒唐可笑。大约在同一时间，纳尔逊生命中一个稍微有些阴郁的人物，基思海军上将，一个绝对是教科书式的选角机构选出的令人生畏的苏格兰人。
Not the kind. He would be impressed by Emma's attitudes. Not at all. He arrives in Gibraltar and he writes home to his sister and he says, everybody says, Nelson is cutting the most absurd figure possible for folly and vanity. There's a French officer called Damat, who's actually serving the Neapolitans, confusingly. And he writes it around the same time, Nelson's officers are increasingly mortified and disgusted by his behavior with the Hamilton's. Now, the question which historians, biographers, are grappled with, which I think Tom and I probably, we have different opinions about, and indeed, Nelson's officers and comrades have different opinions at the time, is how much is this people projecting a kind of misogyny and a snobbery onto the Nelson-Emma relationship?
不是那种会被艾玛的姿态所打动的人。一点也不。他到达直布罗陀，写信给他的妹妹说，每个人都说，纳尔逊因为愚蠢和虚荣而表现得极其荒谬。有一位叫达马特的法国军官，他实际上是在为那不勒斯人服务，这很令人困惑。他在同一时间写道，纳尔逊的军官们对他在汉密尔顿夫妇面前的行为感到越来越羞愧和厌恶。现在，历史学家和传记作者们一直在纠结的问题，我想汤姆和我可能有不同的看法，事实上，纳尔逊的军官和战友们当时也有不同的看法，那就是，这些人有多少是在将一种厌女症和势利眼投射到纳尔逊与艾玛的关系上？
And how much is it, you know, his genuinely slightly nauseating mooning and showing off and victimhood and blah, blah, blah? I think there is definitely a strong vein of misogyny here. So to look at Keith, Keith is arriving to take Nelson's place as commander-in-chief. There are going to be disagreements over Nelson's strategy. Nelson has based himself in Palermo because he sees it as a launch pad for reconquering Naples and for maintaining the blockade. of Malta, Keith doesn't think that this is a valid reason. So there is a kind of deep-seated strategic disagreement there. But it's easier for Keith to cast Nelson's reasons for being in Palermo that he's kind of playing Anthony to Emma's Cleopatra. And it's turbocharged,
又有多少是关于他那令人作呕的迷恋、炫耀和受害者心态等等？我认为这里绝对有一种强烈的厌女症。看看基思，基思到达是为了接替纳尔逊担任总司令。在纳尔逊的战略上会有分歧。纳尔逊将自己驻扎在巴勒莫，因为他将其视为重新征服那不勒斯和维持马耳他封锁的发射台，基思认为这不是一个有效的理由。所以这里存在一种根深蒂固的战略分歧。但基思更容易将纳尔逊留在巴勒莫的原因归结为他在扮演安东尼，而艾玛是克利奥帕特拉。而且它是涡轮增压的，
I think, by what we're talking about earlier, this idea that Naples and Italy and Palermo are like kind of whores, seducing honest British tars and corrupting. them. And actually, you know, the very idea of Parthenopi, the siren, kind of luring sailors onto the rocks. I think that all of this is kind of bubbling away. And in a sense, it becomes easier for both Nelson's critics and his admirers in the Royal Navy to blame Emma for this, which casts Nelson himself as a kind of very, very kind of supine figure, ludicrously supine, rather than engage the fact that actually this is about issues of strategy and questioning Nelson's judgment as a naval and military figure.
我认为，正如我们之前谈到的，这种想法认为那不勒斯、意大利和巴勒莫就像某种诱惑诚实的英国水手并腐蚀他们的妓女。事实上，你知道，帕耳忒诺珀（海妖）诱惑水手触礁的想法。我认为所有这些都在酝酿之中。在某种意义上，纳尔逊的批评者和崇拜者在皇家海军中都更容易将此归咎于艾玛，这使得纳尔逊本人看起来像是一个非常、非常顺从的人物，荒谬地顺从，而不是去探讨这实际上是关于战略问题，并质疑纳尔逊作为海军和军事人物的判断力。
But a quick counter argument, and I know we don't want to get massively bogged down in this, but one might be, you might say, they don't just blame Emma. So actually a lot of this is about blaming Nelson himself. So I think there is probably a degree, I mean, there's no doubt there's a degree of misogyny in the way and snobber in the way that people talk about Emma. But that doesn't necessarily mean that there's no kernel of truth in this as well, and that perhaps Nelson is slightly, you know, the mooning and whatnot, maybe that is slightly embarrassing for a lot of his comrades. I think the other thing is that it's not just about, I mean, clearly, Emma begins to undermine the idea of the band of brothers that has been so important to Nelson. She is Yoko to the Beatles.
但一个快速的反驳论点，我知道我们不想陷入其中，但一个论点可能是，你可能会说，他们不仅仅是责怪艾玛。所以实际上很多是关于责怪纳尔逊本人。所以我认为可能存在一定程度——毫无疑问，人们谈论艾玛的方式中存在一定程度的厌女症和势利眼。但这并不一定意味着这里没有真相的内核，也许纳尔逊确实有点，你知道，那种迷恋等等，对他的许多战友来说可能有点尴尬。我认为另一件事是，这不仅仅是关于——显然，艾玛开始破坏纳尔逊非常看重的“兄弟连”理念。她是披头士乐队里的洋子。
I knew that comparison was coming. Before we'd even, before I even embarked on the research for this, I knew. I'm being very predictable in this episode. But I think her, what she stands for, which is a kind of showiness, I mean, obviously the attitudes are about show and about spectacle and whatnot, that for some of these people who are ingrained in the values of the service, duty, responsibility, you know, I was going to say sobriety, that's not really the right word for the Royal Navy, but you know what I mean. Well, there's a very interesting episode, and you talked about capital.
我知道这个比较会来。在我开始这项研究之前，我就知道了。我在这一集中表现得非常可预测。但我认为她所代表的，即一种炫耀，我是说，显然这些姿态是关于展示和奇观等等，对于那些深受服务价值观、责任感、你知道，我本来想说清醒，但这对皇家海军来说不是合适的词，但你知道我的意思。嗯，有一个非常有趣的插曲，你谈到了船长。
Captain Hardy, he's a great flogger at maintaining discipline. Emma has a reputation among the seamen, the common seaman, as someone who is a woman of compassion who can be appealed to. And there are men who are condemned by Hardy to be flogged. They appeal to Emma. And Hardy then flogs them twice, both for the original crime and because they appealed, you know, over his head to Emma Hamilton. And you can see exactly why that would infuriate Nelson's captains. Yeah, it's that thing. If you've read, anyone who's read the Master and Commander books, the Patrick O'Brien books, there is nothing more destabilizing to a ship. A lot of people argue that when you have a very glamorous, attractive woman on board, and it turns some people's heads and it starts to mess with the chain of command and all of this kind of thing. There's that, there's also something else you alluded to earlier, which is Nelson's love of bling. And I think there's a sense that some people think Nelson is starting to become a little bit un-British, a little bit Italian. Yeah, he's hanging around with Italians. He's got this massive feathered ornament in his hat sent to him by the Sultan, all of this sort of stuff. Now, has Nelson therefore completely lost the plot? I think that would be very harsh, as Andrew Lambert says in his biography, you know, Nelson is exhausted. He may well still have concussion. He has been through this military trial in the Battle of the Nile and the chase that if it happened to, he may well still have concussion. He has been through this military trial in the Battle of the Nile and the chase that if it happened, he may well, he may well still have concussion. He has been, he has been today, you know, anyone who had been through it, you would say, gosh, they must have PTSD,
哈迪船长，他是一个在维持纪律方面非常严厉的人。艾玛在水手，普通水手中享有声誉，被认为是一个可以求助的富有同情心的女人。有些被哈迪判处鞭刑的人向艾玛求助。哈迪随后鞭打了他们两次，一次是因为最初的罪行，另一次是因为他们越级向艾玛·汉密尔顿求助。你可以看出为什么这会激怒纳尔逊的船长们。是的，就是那样。如果你读过帕特里克·奥布莱恩的《怒海争锋》系列，没有什么比这更能破坏一艘船的稳定了。许多人认为，当船上有一位非常有魅力、迷人的女性时，这会让人分心，并开始扰乱指挥链等等。还有你之前提到的另一件事，那就是纳尔逊对珠宝的热爱。我认为有些人认为纳尔逊开始变得有点“不那么英国”，有点“意大利化”了。是的，他和意大利人混在一起。他帽子上戴着苏丹送给他的巨大羽毛装饰，所有这些东西。那么，纳尔逊因此完全失去了理智吗？我认为那会非常苛刻，正如安德鲁·兰伯特在他的传记中所说，你知道，纳尔逊精疲力竭。他可能仍然有脑震荡。他经历了尼罗河海战和追击战的军事考验，如果这发生在他身上，他可能仍然有脑震荡。他经历了，他经历了今天，你知道，任何经历过这一切的人，你都会说，天哪，他们一定有创伤后应激障碍，
they must have this, that, and the other. So probably he is a bit dizzy, as it were, kind of morally and intellectually and emotionally dizzy, and that's not necessarily surprising. But also, he's failed because he had backed this, the, the Neapolitans to attack Rome, and now that seems to have collapsed. And it looks as though everything he'd been trying to do with the stabilization of Italy is, you know, is ashes. And that must make, I mean, that's terrible.
他们一定有这个那个。所以他可能有点头晕，在道德、理智和情感上有点头晕，这并不奇怪。但他也失败了，因为他支持那不勒斯人进攻罗马，而现在这似乎已经崩溃了。看起来他试图通过稳定意大利所做的一切都化为灰烬。这一定让他，我是说，这太可怕了。
for him. He's now got Admiral Keith turning up, whose talent for man management isn't all it could be, I think making him feel a failure. And he, you know, in Palermo, he doesn't really have a kind of secretariat. He doesn't have people on hand who he can turn to. So I can entirely understand the degree of pressure that he's under. Tom is very much, you're, you know, Nelson would love you, Tom. You don't like to hear a word against Nelson. Well, we are approaching the most controversial episode in Nelson's career, and I will have things to say about that. But I do generally feel, I mean, the reason why Nelson is such a remarkable figure is that, firstly, he is genuinely heroic, brilliant admiral. He never lets up on that. And secondly, I think he is genuinely
对他来说。他现在有了基思海军上将的到来，他的管理才能并不像他可能的那样，我认为这让他感到自己是个失败者。而且，你知道，在巴勒莫，他并没有一个秘书处。他手边没有可以求助的人。所以我完全理解他所承受的压力程度。汤姆，你非常，你知道，纳尔逊会喜欢你的，汤姆。你不喜欢听到任何反对纳尔逊的话。好吧，我们正在接近纳尔逊职业生涯中最具争议的一集，我会对此发表看法。但我确实总体上觉得，我是说，纳尔逊之所以是一个如此非凡的人物，首先是因为他确实是一位英勇、杰出的海军上将。他从未放弃过这一点。其次，我认为他确实
a man of honour. And what happens in Italy is a drag on that reputation. He starts to betray his wife, but also he gets led by the swirl of Italian power politics into a whirlpool that doesn't leave him looking quite as honourable as I think in the main he tends to be. Okay, well, let's get into this. So what's been going on in Naples while he's been swanning around in Palermo with Emma? The French have occupied the city. They've cracked down on the Lazzaroni. They've abolished the monarchy.
是一个有荣誉感的人。而在意大利发生的事情损害了他的声誉。他开始背叛他的妻子，而且他被意大利权力政治的漩涡带入了一个漩涡，这让他看起来不像我所认为的那样光荣。好吧，让我们深入探讨一下。当他在巴勒莫和艾玛闲逛时，那不勒斯发生了什么？法国人占领了这座城市。他们镇压了拉扎罗尼（那不勒斯平民），废除了君主制。
They've set up a new Parthenopian Republic run by the poets. writers and whatnot, the so-called Jacobin. As we said, this is an elite from quite a narrow social group. So intellectuals, people who are freemasons, people who are merchants. The majority of the Neapolitan population are very Catholic, quite small-sea conservative, and monochist. And outside the city, this new regime has very little support at all. And there are immediately rebellions all over rural Calabria. Now, King Ferdinand, seething in his sort of oafish way in Palermo, thinks brilliant, and he sends an agent to lead this fight back.
他们建立了一个由诗人、作家之类的人，即所谓的雅各宾派所领导的新帕特诺佩共和国。正如我们所说，这是一个来自相当狭窄社会群体的精英阶层。所以是知识分子、共济会成员、商人。那不勒斯的大多数人口是非常虔诚的天主教徒，属于小写的保守派，并且是君主制支持者。在城市之外，这个新政权几乎没有什么支持。卡拉布里亚农村地区立即爆发了叛乱。现在，费迪南德国王在巴勒莫以他那种笨拙的方式怒火中烧，他认为这太棒了，于是派了一名特工去领导这场反击。
And this guy is a former treasurer to the papacy in his 50s called Cardinal Rufo. Rufo has never commanded an army before, but he's a smart guy. He knows what he's doing. He lands on the mainland in early February. He raises the standard of the Holy Cross. He says, come on, fight for your church, fight for your king. And he recruits 20,000 volunteers who are called the soldiers or the army of the holy faith. And these are the San Fadisti.
这个人是一位50多岁的前教廷财务官，名叫鲁福枢机主教。鲁福以前从未指挥过军队，但他是个聪明人。他知道自己在做什么。他在二月初抵达意大利大陆。他竖起了圣十字旗。他说，来吧，为你们的教会而战，为你们的国王而战。他招募了2万名志愿者，被称为“圣信军”或“圣信军队”。这些人就是圣信派。
And these are, I think, riffraff is probably the most generous way to the first. They are kind of ruffians. Ruffo's riffraff. Yeah, they're kind of bandits, criminals and whatnot. And they're like, great. All restraints are off. We're going to enjoy this. They advance through Calabria.
我认为，用“乌合之众”来形容他们可能是最客气的说法。他们有点像暴徒。鲁福的乌合之众。是的，他们有点像强盗、罪犯之类的。他们觉得，太好了。所有的约束都没有了。我们要好好享受一番。他们穿过卡拉布里亚。
When they get into a town, they take town off the town. They will loot and pillage. They lynch people. They find somebody who kind of speaks French, who's a Freemason, who's got Republican or reformist sympathies. String them up. String them up, exactly. If they've basically, if they can't find them,
当他们进入一个城镇时，他们会一个接一个地占领城镇。他们会抢劫和掠夺。他们会私刑处死人们。他们找到那些会说法语的人，或者是共济会成员，或者是对共和派或改革派有同情心的人。把他们吊死。没错，就是把他们吊死。如果他们基本上找不到这些人，
they'll string some other people up anyway just for the fun of it. And Cardinal Rufo is, I mean, he's very upset about this. But there's not a lot of you. can do. There's nothing he can do. Because his riffraff are riffraffing. They're not going to listen to him. Anyway, by the beginning of May 1799, they pretty much surrounded Naples. This republic is clearly doomed. The French troops, the French garrison, they hold up in the Castel-Sant Elmo, which overlooks the city. And the so-called Jacobin, they hold up in two other castles on the waterfront, the Castadellovo and the Castel Nouveauvo. And basically, they know, if the San Francisco get into the city and get
他们也会随便吊死其他人，纯粹是为了好玩。鲁福枢机主教，我的意思是，他对此感到非常不安。但你对此无能为力。他什么也做不了。因为他的乌合之众正在胡作非为。他们不会听他的。总之，到1799年5月初，他们几乎包围了那不勒斯。这个共和国显然注定要灭亡。法国军队，即法国驻军，躲在俯瞰城市的圣埃尔莫城堡中。而所谓的雅各宾派，则躲在海滨的另外两座城堡里，即蛋堡和新堡。基本上，他们知道，如果圣信派进入城市并抓住我们，他们真的会把我们撕成碎片。鲁福枢机主教，值得称赞的是，他觉得我真的不想看到这座城市被摧毁，我不想发生大规模的血洗，长话短说，把极其复杂的故事简化，他实际上想与雅各宾派达成协议。他们投降，从城堡里出来，我们把他们送上港口的船，他们可以去法国的土伦，我们将永远摆脱他们，也不会再有杀戮。而费迪南德和玛丽亚·卡罗琳娜显然不喜欢这个主意，因为对他们来说非常重要的一点是，
hold of us, they will literally tear us to pieces. Cardinal Rufo, to his credit, it's like, I don't really want to see the city destroyed, I don't want a massive bloodbath, and to cut a very long and incredibly complicated story short, he effectively wants to do a deal with the Jacabat. They'll surrender, they'll come out of the castles, we'll put them on boats in the harbour, and they can go off to Toulon in France, and we'll be rid of them forever, and there won't be any more killing. And Ferdinand and Maria Carolina, clearly do not like this idea because it's really important to them
特别是那些头目必须受到惩罚，不能让他们逍遥法外。尤其是那些他们认为亲自背叛了他们的人。这类人中有一个代表性人物，叫弗朗切斯科·卡拉乔洛。他是那不勒斯的贵族，
that the ringleaders in particular are punished that they cannot be allowed to get away, scot-free. And particularly those who they feel have personally betrayed them. And there's a kind of a representative figure of that class of person who's a guy called Francesco Caracciolo. And he's an aristocrat from Naples
他实际上曾在皇家海军服役，既对抗过美国独立战争中的美国人，也参加过拿破仑战争，他还曾帮助护送王室成员从那不勒斯前往巴勒莫，之后又回到巴勒莫并加入了革命。所以他是国王和王后迫切希望看到受到惩罚的那类人的代表。没错。现在，他们想找人亲自处理这件事，因为他们不信任鲁福能做到。于是6月10日，费迪南德国王请求纳尔逊，请你航行回那不勒斯，
who had actually served with the Royal Navy, both against the Americans in the War of Independence, in the Napoleonic Wars, and he had helped to escort the royal family from Naples to Palermo, had then gone back to Palermo and had joined the revolution. So he's a kind of representative of the kind of man that the king and queen are desperate to see punished. Exactly. Now, they want somebody to handle this personally because they don't trust Rufo to do it. And so on the 10th of June, King Ferdinand asks Nelson, can you sail back to Naples, please?
监督收复城市并处理这些城堡里雅各宾派的问题。现在，纳尔逊在这里必须做出选择，但公平地说，他从伦敦收到的命令非常明确。给予国王和王后他们需要的保护，并重申，避免给他们任何引起怀疑、嫉妒或冒犯的最小理由。所以两天后，他带着一支小部队出发前往巴勒莫。现在，当他航行时，那不勒斯陷入了彻底的混乱。鲁福的军队闯入城市。他们开始了对城市的洗劫。成千上万的建筑物被洗劫和焚烧。
supervise the retaking of the city and handle this issue of the Jacobin in these castles. Now, Nelson has a choice to make here, but his orders from London, to be fair to him, are pretty clear. Give the king and queen of protection they need, and to repeat, avoid giving them the smallest cause for suspicion, jealousy, or offence. So two days later, he sets off for Palermo with a small army. Now, while he's sailing, Naples descends into total, and utter chaos. Rufo's army break into the city. They begin the kind of sack of the city. Thousands of buildings ransacked and burns.
成百上千的人，我的意思是，我们无法确定，但成百上千的人被屠杀。基本上，如果你看起来有点像自由派，换句话说，如果你，例如，留着短发，这是共和派同情的标志，这是一种罗马式发型，那么很有可能有人会把你刺在长矛上，抬着你穿过街道。所以基本上，这些在城堡里的雅各宾派陷入了极度的恐惧。他们恳求鲁福达成协议，最终在6月22日签署了所谓的投降书。基本上就是这样。他们会从城堡里出来。他们会交出所有的武器。鲁福会让他们去土伦，事情就这样结束了。当玛丽亚·卡罗琳娜听到这个消息时，她简直愤怒到了极点。我可以读出她对艾玛说了什么吗？你要用她的声音读吗？是的。这是一部卑劣的杰作，如此卑劣和荒谬，以至于我连谈论它都感到反感。
Hundreds of people, I mean, we can't be sure, but hundreds of people are slaughtered. Basically, if you look vaguely kind of liberal, in other words, if you, for example, have short hair, which is a sign of Republican sympathy, it's a kind of Roman haircut, then there's a good chance that somebody will impale you on a pike and carry you through the... streets. So basically, these Jacobin and the castles were in a total funk. They beg Rufo for a deal and they end up signing this what's called a capitulation on the 22nd of June. It's basically this. They'll come out the castles. They'll give over any weapons they have. Rufo will let them go to Toulon and that will be the end of that. And when Maria Carolina hears this, she is absolutely furious. Can I read out what she tells Emma? You're going to do it in her voice? Yeah. It's a masterpiece of infamy, so infamous and absurd that it revolts me even to speak of it.
你看，你知道吗？我知道你和爱德华·哈布斯堡有联系，他是哈布斯堡火炬的传递者。如果他听到你用那种方式模仿哈布斯堡口音，他会非常生气的。我不认为奥利弗有那么多性格。她有女人的身体，但有男人的声音。好吧，总之，三天后，也就是25日，纳尔逊带着18艘战列舰抵达那不勒斯，他现在面临一个重大决定。一方面，鲁福枢机主教没有权力与雅各宾派达成这项协议。他们实际上还待在这些城堡里。他们还没有出来。所以纳尔逊可以说，好吧，这个协议什么也不是。它是无效的。你们仍然处于叛乱状态，你们应该受到惩戒性的惩罚。另一方面，荣誉可能要求既然协议已经达成，你就必须遵守协议。显然，城堡里的雅各宾派自己也认为协议仍然有效，因为就在第二天，即26日，他们按照约定走出城堡，交出武器，并被护送到在港口等待的那不勒斯船只上。所以他们心想，太棒了。感谢上帝，我们活着出来了。
See, do you know what? I know that you're in touch with Edward Hapsberg, the bearer of the Hapsberg torch. He would be very offended that you've done a Hapsberg accent in that way. I don't think so much character from Oliver. She has the body of woman, but the voice of a man. Right. Well, anyway, three days after that, so on the 25th, Nelson arrives in Naples with 18 ships of the line, and he now has a big decision to make. On the one hand, Cardinal Rufo had no authority to do this deal with the Jacabat. They're actually still in these castles. They haven't come out yet. So Nelson could say, well, this deal is a nothing deal. It's null and void. You're still in rebellion, and you deserve exemplary punishment. On the other hand, honor might demand that the deal has been agreed, and you honor the deal. And clearly the Jacquet in the castles themselves think the deal is still on, because the very next day, the 26th, they march out of the castles as agreed, they hand over their weapons, and they're escorted to Neapolitan ships waiting in the harbor. So they're thinking, brilliant. Thank God we've come out of this for their lives.
这些人有成千上万，对吧？我的意思是，你知道，五到一万人左右之类的。没错。没错。他们假设，按照协议，我们正在前往土伦的路上。共和国没有成功。谢天谢地，这件事没有以可怕的血洗告终。我们可以信赖纳尔逊海军上将，作为一个英国人，一个有荣誉感的人，他已经给了我们承诺，所有这些。
And these are thousands of people, right? I mean, you know, five to 10,000 people or something like that. Exactly. Exactly. And they assume, as per the deal, we're on our way to Toulon. The Republic hasn't worked out. Thank goodness this has ended without a terrible bloodbath. And we can rely on Admiral Nelson as an Englishman, man of honor, given his word, all of that.
好吧，他并没有给出他的承诺，不是吗？不，但他会给的。我想，这就是，你知道，他不会就这样把他们吊死。这正是他们所想的。现在，两天后，纳尔逊下令将一些雅各宾派开始转移到港口的英国船只上，转移到皇家海军的船只上。与此同时，其他囚犯也从城市被带上船。这些人是被那种乌合之众暴徒围捕的人。
Well, he hasn't given his word, has he? No, but he will. That, I guess, is, you know, he's not going to just string them up. That's exactly what they think. Now, two days after that, Nelson orders that some of the Chequabam start to be transferred to British. ships in the harbour to Royal Navy ships. And at the same time, other prisoners are being brought aboard from the city. These are people who have been rounded up by the kind of the riff-raff mobs.
这显然对被带上英国船只的雅各宾派来说是一个巨大的打击，对纳尔逊自己的船长们来说也是一个打击。我们拥有的每一个来源都有一个议程，有不同的议程。所以，你知道，你必须稍微小心一点。但根据英国领事查尔斯·洛克的说法，虽然他确实不是纳尔逊的粉丝。他描述了纳尔逊的两名船长，塞缪尔·胡德和本杰明·哈洛韦尔，是如何立即找到纳尔逊并说，这根本不对。这些人以为他们实际上是在我们的保护之下。
And this is clearly a great shock to the Jacques-A-Bah who are being brought aboard the British ships and is a shock to Nelson's own captains. Every source that we have on this has an agenda, has a different agenda. So, you know, you have to be a little bit careful. But according to the British consul, Charles Locke, admittedly not a fan of Nelson. He described how two of Nelson's captains, Samuel Hood and Benjamin Hallowell, immediately went to Nelson and said, this is not right at all. Like these people thought they were effectively under our protection.
我们要么应该让他们按约定去土伦，如果我们不打算这样做，我们应该让他们回到城堡，基本上恢复围攻，进行一场公平的战斗。这不光彩。这是对他们的背信弃义。至关重要的是，这不是我们在皇家海军中的行为方式。这不是我们应该做的。对我来说，这听起来确实有可信度，纳尔逊对他们发火了，他说，我看到你们都反对我，那种他经常有的轻微的自怜。我决心服从我的命令，无论对错，它都必须完成，我会被服从的。对我来说，那是某人实际上对自己所做的事情感到有点内疚的语气，
Either we should let them go to Toulon, as agreed, or if we're not going to do that, we should let them go back to the castles and basically resume the siege, like have a fair fight of it. this is not honorable. It's a breach of faith with them. Crucially, it's not how we behave in the Royal Navy. This is not what we should do. And this, to me, does have the ring of plausibility that Nelson snaps at them and he says, I see you all against me, the slight self-pity that he often has. I'm determined to obey my orders, right or wrong, it shall be done, I will be obeyed. To me, that is the tone of somebody who actually feels a little bit guilty about what he's doing
并且知道这并不完全光彩，但他觉得他被困住了，别无选择。那么对此该怎么看呢？我的意思是，对此有非常、非常广泛的观点，对吧？是的。因为结果是一系列的处决。是的，是的。所以如果我们谈到处决，我们提到了卡拉乔洛，那位海军上将，他们认为他是叛徒。他一直伪装成农民躲藏起来。所以他穿着破烂的衣服被拖到纳尔逊面前。
and knows it's not entirely honourable, but feels he's trapped and he has no choice. So what to make of this? I mean, there are a very, very broad range of opinions on this, right? Yeah. Because the upshot is a series of executions. Yes, yeah. So if we get into the executions, so we mentioned Caracciolo, the Admiral, who's, they see as a traitor. And he's been hiding out disguised as a peasant. So he gets dragged in front of Nelson in his rags.
是的。纳尔逊召开了军事法庭，记住，这是在英国船上。而且他曾在皇家海军服役。是的。所以纳尔逊的许多军官都带着同情看着这个人。你知道，他是他们的老战友。是的，有一个军事法庭，他被判有罪，并被判处绞刑。纳尔逊的一些军官对他说，你难道不能至少减刑，让他被枪决吗？你知道，他可以以一种更得体、更有尊严的方式死去。纳尔逊说，还有其他人说，为什么不推迟这件事呢？等费迪南德国王抵达那不勒斯。也许他会赦免这个人，或者也许，你知道，他会自己做决定，这不会落在我们头上。纳尔逊说，不，我不会等。我有我的命令。卡拉乔洛被从帆桁上吊死。他一直挂在那里直到日落，然后他的尸体被扔进海里。他们给他加了重物，随后他又浮了上来。是的，它漂浮了很长时间。看起来白白的，又白又绿。一位英国中尉说，我不得不说，这让我觉得很有趣，这可能不应该让他们觉得有趣。
Yes. Nelson convenes a court-martial, remember, this is on a British ship. And he'd been serving with the Royal Navy. Yeah. So a lot of Nelson's, you know, officers are looking at this guy with sympathy. You know, he's their old comrade. He is, there's a court marshal, he's found guilty, and his sentence to be hanged. And some of Nelson's officers say to him, could you not at least commute the sentence so that he's shot? You know, he can die in a more decorous, dignified way. And Nelson said, and some of the others say, why not hold off on this? Wait for King Ferdinand to arrive. in Naples. Maybe he'll pardon this guy, or maybe, you know, he'll take the decision himself and it won't be on us. And Nelson says, no, I'm not going to wait. Like, I've got my orders. Caracciolo is hanged from the yard arm. He hangs there until sunset and then his body is thrown into the sea. And they weigh him down and then subsequently it bobs back up again. Yes, it's floating around for ages. Looking all kind of white, white and green. One British lieutenant says, I have to say, this amused me, which it probably shouldn't do them.
我们舰队的海员们安慰自己说，那只不过是一个意大利王子和那不勒斯的海军上将，吊死一个与英国船上地位最低的人相比地位非常轻微的人，这就是那种斗牛犬精神。现在，这为接下来的事情定下了基调，法国军队被允许去土伦，
the seamen of our fleet consoled themselves that it was only an Italian prince and the admiral of Naples that was hanging a person of very light estimation compared with the lowest man in a British ship the bulldog spirit there now that sets the tone for what follows the French troops are allowed to go to too long
你知道，他们就像当他们撤离堡垒时，是的，因为他们是战俘，我想这会是纳尔逊的想法，他们不是叛徒，是的，所以也许，谁能说得准呢？也许有8000人左右被送上法庭。而纳尔逊本人并没有卷入那个过程，是吗？不，但其中一些人是在他的旗舰上受审的。
you know they are like when they evacuate their fort yeah because they're prisoners of war I guess would be Nelson's thinking they're not traitors yes so maybe I mean who can say Maybe 8,000 people or so are put on trial. And Nelson himself is not embroiled in that process, is he? No, but some of them are tried on board his flagship.
当然。好吧，纳尔逊对此表示赞同。我的意思是，他认为这太棒了。我的意思是，他说他祝贺自己把法国人赶到了魔鬼那里，并恢复了人类的和平与幸福。毫无疑问，他认为这个处决过程是恢复人类和平与幸福过程的一部分。但他并不是，不像卡拉乔洛那样，他亲自处理法律程序？不。我的意思是，处决，所以被处决的人数，有非常
Of course. Well, Nelson approves of it. I mean, he thinks it's tremendous. I mean, he says he congratulates himself on driving the French to the devil and in restoring peace and happiness to mankind. And undoubtedly, he sees this process of executions as being part of that process of restoring peace and happiness to mankind. But he's not, it's not as it had been. say with Caracchioli, that he is personally handling the legal process? No. I mean, the execution, so the number of people who are executed, there are very
不同的估计。也许有3000人被关进监狱。也许有100、120、150人被处决。处决通常相当残酷。如果你幸运的话，你的头会被砍掉。如果你不幸的话，你基本上会被放在梯子上，脖子上套着绳子，然后街头顽童会抓住你的脚，有效地把你吊死。所以这不是最好的死法。费迪南德和玛丽亚·卡罗琳娜对这一切感到非常高兴。他们向纳尔逊的船长们、他的船员们分发奖励，你知道，很多珠宝。纳尔逊自己也得到了更多的珠宝。他得到了一把曾经属于路易十四的镶钻剑。最重要的是，作为他的主要奖励，他得到了他的公爵爵位。他被封为布隆特公爵，这是一个
different estimates. Maybe about 3,000 people are put into prison. Maybe about 100, 120, 150 are executed. The executions are often pretty grim. If you're lucky, you'll have your head chopped off. If you're unlucky, you're basically put onto a ladder with a rope around your neck and then street urchins will cling to your feet to hang you effectively. So it's not the best way to die. Ferdinand and Maria Carolina are delighted with all this. They hand out rewards to Nelson's captains, to his crews, you know, lots of bling. Nelson gets loads more bling himself. He gets a diamond studded sword that once belonged to Louis XIV. And above all, as his chief reward, he gets his dukedom. He's made the Duke of Bronte, which is a
西西里岛的一个城镇，位于埃特纳火山的山脚下，这对纳尔逊变得非常重要。奇怪的是，他从来没有去过那里。但他梦想在那里退休，不是吗？是的，去一个他从未去过的地方。就像一个英国广告主管退休到普罗旺斯。这正是它的样子。在他心中，它就像一种，你知道，普罗旺斯的房子之类的。实际上，我认为它相当破旧，他会发现它非常令人失望。
is a town in Sicily, in the foothills of Mount Etna, which becomes enormously important to Nelson. The weird thing is he never, ever visits it. He dreams of retiring there, though, doesn't he? Yeah, to a place has never been. Like a British advertising executive retiring to Provence. That's exactly what it is. He, in his mind, it is like a kind of, you know, a sort of a house in Provence or whatever. In reality, it's rather run down, I think, and he'd have found it very disappointing.
他雇佣了一位非常有效的土地代理人，我想他把它整理成了一些样子。但我同意。我不认为它不是普罗旺斯。从那时起，他总是自称纳尔逊和布隆特。他当然会。同样，这也是那种对英国的一些人来说有点尴尬的事情。你知道，拜托，你应该超越这种事情。我的意思是，我们知道纳尔逊对此的感觉，那不勒斯国王以一种不列颠国王明显未能做到的方式奖励了他。
He employs a very effective land agent who I think whips it into some kind of shape. But I agree. I don't think it's not Provence. And he always, from this point on, would sides himself, Nelson and Bronte. Of course he does. And again, this is the kind of thing that to some people in Britain is just a bit embarrassing. You know, come on, you should be above this kind of thing. I mean, we know how Nelson feels about it, that the king of Naples has rewarded him in a way that, you know, his Britannic majesty has signally failed to do.
现在，这些处决的消息开始传播得相当快。我之前提到了一个叫查尔斯·洛克的人，他是英国领事。他已经反对纳尔逊和艾玛，特别是他的妻子讨厌艾玛。正是洛克，是在英国传播处决消息的关键人物。他写信回家说，纳尔逊完全失去了理智。他以一种非常不英国的方式成为了这种嗜血复仇的帮凶。而且他受到了艾玛的鼓励，她是一个彻头彻尾的怪物。我们知道流言传播得非常快，因为例如，在几周内，
Now, news of these. executions begins to spread quite quickly. And I mentioned a guy, I think earlier, called Charles Locke, who is the British consul. He has turned against Nelson and Emma, in particular because his wife hates Emma. And it's Locke, who is the key person in spreading the news of the executions in Britain. He writes home and he says, Nelson's completely lost the plot. He is an accessory to this bloodthirsty vengeance in a very un-British way. And he's been encouraged by Emma, who is a total and utter monster. And we know that the gossip spread very quickly because, for example, within a few weeks,
社会上的一位假发女主人叫贝斯佩拉夫人写道，我读到关于那不勒斯残酷行为的报道感到非常痛苦，但最糟糕的是，我亲爱的、令人愉快的纳尔逊竟然让自己卷入如此可耻的行为。我希望报道不是真的，因为我只是在报纸上读到的，因为我无法忍受。所以这是纳尔逊名誉上的巨大污点。毫无疑问，这是他职业生涯中最具争议的事件，我的意思是，最臭名昭著的。所以对此有一系列观点，不是吗？
society kind of wig hostess called Lady Bespera is writing, I am miserable at the accounts I've read of the cruelties at Naples, but worst of all that my dear delightful Nelson should have let himself be drawn in to so disgraceful an action. I hope the account's not true, as I've only read it in the newspapers for I cannot bear it. So this is the great blot on Nelson's escutcheon. This is, without a doubt, the most controversial episode in his career, I mean, the most notorious. And so there's a kind of a range of perspectives on it, isn't there?
是的。同样，我认为这是一件听众可以在某种程度上自己做决定的事情。但如果你从一个极端开始，安德鲁·兰伯特，非常伟大的海军历史学家，他说，纳尔逊不仅没有做错任何事。纳尔逊表现得非常出色。兰伯特说死亡人数是微不足道的。这是一个直接引用。战时叛乱失败的惩罚是众所周知的。他说这些人基本上是所有美好和正确事物的敌人。他们是自找的。当他们叛乱时，他们知道会发生什么。为什么这里有什么可争论的？纳尔逊绝对做了正确的事。然后中间你有约翰·萨格登，你知道，泰坦尼克号般的纳尔逊传记可能是最权威的。他说纳尔逊在这里处于一个不可能的境地。他要么，你知道，他的命令是坚持支持那不勒斯的国王和王后。他能做什么？你知道，他真的无法摆脱它。然后你有更具批判性的罗杰·奈特。罗杰·奈特说，你知道，这是纳尔逊职业生涯中唯一一个他没有
Yeah. Again, I think it's a thing, it's one of these things that the listeners can make up their own minds to some degree. But if you start at one extreme, Andrew Lambert, very great naval historian, he says, Not only did Nelson do nothing wrong. Nelson behaved absolutely brilliantly. Lambert says the death toll was trifling. That's a direct quote. The penalty for a failed rebellion in time of war was well understood. He says these people were basically the enemies of all that is good and right. They had it coming. They knew what was when they had their rebellion. They knew what was coming. Why is there anything to debate here? Nelson absolutely did the right thing. Then in the middle you have John Sugden, who's you know, Titanic Nelson biography is probably the definitive one. He says Nelson's in an impossible situation here. He can either, you know, his orders are to stick to the King and Queen of Naples. What can he do? You know, he can't really get out of it. And then you have more critical Roger Knight. Roger Knight says, you know, this is the one moment in Nelson's career when he doesn't
达到标准的时刻。如果他更聪明，如果他更有经验，更审慎，更反思，他会争取时间，他会等到费迪南德国王抵达那不勒斯，然后他会让国王做这一切，他不会在英国船只上做这一切，所有这些事情，他有点让自己失望了，
measure up. If he'd been smart, if he'd been more experienced, more measured, more reflective, he would have played for time he would have waited till King Ferdinand arrived in Naples and then he'd have let the king do it all and he wouldn't have done it on British ships and all of this kind of thing and he sort of let himself down there
罗杰·奈特说这是因为我引用他那天真地依附于汉密尔顿夫妇和玛丽亚·卡罗琳娜，甚至到了阿谀奉承的地步，这绝对是一个污点，而且实际上还有一个更具批判性的观点，不是吗？乔纳森·诺斯。
and Roger Knight says this is because I quote his naive attachment to the point of sycophancy to the Hamilton's and to Maria Carolina and that this is definitely a black mark and there's actually a even more critical take isn't it? Jonathan North
是的。所以他的书在疫情前刚出版。所以我想是2018年，叫《纳尔逊在那不勒斯》。他基本上读了关于这个主题的所有可以想象到的来源。他的结论实际上是非常严厉的。所以引用他的话，我的观点，在看了尽可能多的材料后，是纳尔逊确实在那不勒斯犯下了罪行，并犯有背叛囚犯的罪。所以，我，而且我，你知道，这是一个非常、非常全面的来源分析。而且，你知道，我被它说服了。与此同时，我也认为萨格登的观点有价值，这是一个混乱和动荡的局面。我认为纳尔逊做出了错误的决定。但我可以理解那些可能导致他表现得不如他通常那样光彩的压力。但我确实认为他犯了战争罪。我确实认为他有过错？老实说，我不知道我对此怎么想。我想事实是最令人痛心的，不是任何历史学家怎么想，也不是我们怎么想。而是纳尔逊的同时代人怎么想。我们知道纳尔逊在皇家海军中的一些朋友和战友
Yes. So his book came out just before the pandemic. So 2018, I think, called Nelson at Naples. And he's basically read every conceivable source there is on this topic. And his conclusion is actually very damning. And so to quote him, my view, after having looked at as much of the material as possible, is that Nelson did indeed commit a crime at Naples and was guilty of betraying the prisoners. So I, and I, you know, it's a very, very comprehensive. analysis of the sources. And, you know, I'm convinced by it. At the same time, I do also think that Sugden's point has value that this is a chaotic and turbulent situation. I think Nelson makes the wrong decision. But I can understand the stresses that perhaps led him to behave in a less honorable way than was his norm. But I do think he committed war crimes. I do think he was at fault? I don't know what I think about this, to be brutally honest. I guess the truth is the most damning thing is not what any historian thinks or what we think. It's what Nelson's own contemporaries thought. And we know that some of Nelson's friends and comrades in the Royal Navy
认为他表现得很差，不是吗？我认为他的船长们，他那种兄弟连的成员，说，你知道，你不必这样做，而且在英国船上这样做，这根本不对。当他们被承诺安全通行时，这根本不对。我觉得这非常有说服力。是的，这显然是舆论氛围的一部分，即使在特拉法尔加之后，纳尔逊的死亡，他的神化。所以由桂冠诗人、拜伦的死敌罗伯特·骚塞撰写的第一部关于纳尔逊的著名传记，非常赞美，认为纳尔逊很出色。但他确实在这一集里说，这是纳尔逊记忆和英国荣誉上的污点。
thought he very poorly, don't we? And I think the fact that his own captains, members of his kind of band of brothers, said, you know, you don't have to do this and to do it on a British ship, it's just not right. When they guys have been promised for safe passage, it's just not right. I feel that that's pretty overwhelming. Yeah, and this is clearly part of the climate of opinion, even in the wake of Trafalgar, Nelson's death, is apotheosis. So the first kind of celebrated biography of Nelson written by Robert Sow, the poet laureate, great enemy of Byron, who's very laudatory thinks Nelson is brilliant. But he does say about this episode that it is a stain on the memory of Nelson and upon the honour of England.
是的。我认为人们太爱纳尔逊了，以至于他们不想相信这是真的。我不知道你是否读过巴里·昂斯沃思的小说《失去纳尔逊》，它是关于一个纳尔逊的学者，一个纳尔逊的传记作者，他对他如此着迷，以至于他因为纳尔逊可能表现不佳的可能性而发疯。我认为，你知道，纳尔逊的传记作者，我认为非常不愿意面对他可能把事情搞得如此糟糕的可能性。我认为他的同时代人，他的船长们，他的朋友们也是如此。所以对我来说，一个简单的解决方法，
Yeah. And I think that people at my Nelson so much that they don't want to believe it's true. I don't know if you've read Barry Unsworth's novel, Losing Nelson, which is about a kind of scholar of Nelson, a biographer of Nelson, who's so obsessed by him that he's driven mad by the possibility that Nelson might have behaved poorly. And I think that, you know, biographers of Nelson, I think are very reluctant to face up to the possibility that he might have have got things so badly wrong. And I think that's true of his contemporaries as well, of his captains, of his friends. So for me, one easy fix, as it were,
就是说即使是英雄和令人印象深刻的人也有弱点。在战争时期，你正在做出，你知道，一个又一个不可能的决定，你知道，你很有可能做错一两个，它们看起来非常不光彩，并产生可怕的后果。我的意思是，这就是指挥一个成百上千人、成千上万人的生命取决于你的决定的时代的本质。但多米尼克，当然，还有另一个解决方法，那就是把一切都归咎于一个女人。有一个方便的女人可以被指责。是的。所以这马上就开始了。所以我们提到了在英国传播的故事。荷兰夫人，汤姆，几周后在她的日记中写道。那不勒斯现在展示了一个场景
is to say even heroic and impressive people have feet of clay. And in time of war where you're making, you know, impossible decision after impossible decision, you know, there's every chance that you'll get one or two of them wrong and that they'll look very dishonorable and have terrible consequences. I mean, that's the nature of commanding a time when hundreds of people's, thousands of people's lives depend upon your decisions. But Dominic, of course, there is another fix, which is to blame everything on a woman. And there is a convenient woman to hand who can be blamed. Yeah. So this starts straight away. So we mentioned the story spreading in England. Lady Holland of all people, Tom, wrote in her journal a few weeks later. Naples now exhibits a scene
比西西里晚祷更血腥的复仇，汉密尔顿夫人并没有在增加这种激怒每个人的野蛮行径方面有所懈怠。现在，我知道这一集很长，所以我们没有时间深入探讨这一切。但很明显，在故事传播后不久，人们就开始说，哦，好吧，这全是艾玛·汉密尔顿的错。她和王后太亲近了。她在名单上加名字。她在处决发生时庆祝，所有这些事情。也许她是，但我认为这可能被夸大了，而且可能，我的意思是，这是一个我认为很明显有很多投射，很多麦克白夫人式的东西在发生的情况。是的，绝对。
of revenge more bloody than the Sicilian Vespers, Lady Hamilton has not been remiss in adding her quota to the barbarity, which inflames every breast. Now, I know this has been quite a long episode, so we don't have time to delve massively into all this. But it's pretty clear that quite soon after the story is spread, people started to say, oh, well, it was all Emma Hamilton's full. She's so close to the queen. She was adding names to the list. She was celebrating while the executions were taking place, all of this kind of thing. Maybe she was, but I think it's probably exaggerated and probably, I mean, here's a case where I think quite clearly there's an awful lot of projection, a lot of Lady Macbeth kind of stuff going on. Yes, absolutely.
而且我认为也有明确的证据表明，实际上，你知道，我们谈到了艾玛试图让那些被哈迪船长鞭打的人免受惩罚。她显然，她和王后太亲近了，人们带着请求来找她，她要求放过这些人。她给了王后一份长长的名单。她自己也加了进去。王后说，不，你太心软了。同样，我认为有时她会代表王后感到不安，或者她觉得，比如卡拉乔洛，她为他的处决干杯。手里拿着酒杯，对吧？手里拿着酒杯。而且我认为她觉得，他既背叛了她心爱的皇家海军，也背叛了她心爱的王后。所以我认为她是一个非常情绪化的女人，显然在为一位海军上将的处决干杯和去见她非常亲近的人，即王后，说，请放过所有这些人并被拒绝之间摇摆。但我认为那里可能有足够的东西，你知道，为一位
And I think also there is clear evidence that actually, you know, we talked about Emma trying to get the men who are being flogged by Captain Hardy off their punishment. she is clearly, she's so close to the queen, people are coming to her with requests and she is asking for people to be let off. She gives the queen a kind of long list. She adds to it herself. The queen says, no, you're far too soft-hearted. Equally, I think there are times when she is upset on behalf of the queen or she feels, say with Coraccioli, who she toasts his execution. With a wine glass in hand, right? With a wine glass in her hand. And I think she feels, that he's been a traitor both to her beloved Royal Navy and to her beloved Queen. So I think she's a very emotional woman who clearly swings between toasting the execution of an admiral and kind of going to someone who she's very close to, namely the Queen and saying, please let all these people off and being rebuffed. But I think there's probably enough there, you know, raising a toast to an execution of an
海军上将的处决干杯，纳尔逊船上的许多人都会认识他。你可以看出这些故事是如何传播的。所以，汤姆，这太令人失望了，因为这本来是要成为一场巨大的争论。而实际上，我们俩最终都采取了更审慎的立场。我们毕竟变成了《其余就是政治》。我们确实变成了。我们愉快地达成了一致。哦，不。
admiral who lots of people on Nelson's ships would have known. You can see how these stories would have spread. So, Tom, this is so disappointing because this was set up to be a massive argument. And actually, we've both ended up taking much more measured positions. We've basically turned into the rest as politics after all. We have. We're agreeing agreeably. Oh, no.
好吧。但这一切背后的东西是我们下次要讨论的。因为这一切背后的东西是纳尔逊和艾玛·汉密尔顿之间不断加深的关系。因为正如我们所说，在1799年初的某个时候，他们已经开始了一段恋情。当我们展望下一集时，纳尔逊正在准备。他最终将回到英国。在那里，他将面临他一生中也许最危险、最无情的对手。当然，那不是法国人。
Right. But what lies behind this is what we'll be coming to next time. Because what lies behind all this is the deepening relationship between Nelson and Emma Hamilton. Because as we have said, at some point in the early months of 1799, they have begun an affair. And as we look ahead to the next episode, Nelson is preparing. He will eventually return to England. And there he will face perhaps the most threatening and implacable adversary of his life. It is, of course, not the French.
那是英国人民的反对和嘲笑。好吧，令人难以置信的兴奋。多么，多么悬念。如果你想听所有后续的五集，那么你可以通过访问The Restis History.com并在那里注册来做到这一点。但现在，我要说再见了。再见。过去50年的人。鲁珀特·默多克。我认为你可以说他是20世纪下半叶最有影响力的人物。他在我们这个时代掌权的时间比任何人都长。而且这是有意义的权力。这是非凡的权力。没有责任的权力，这是历代妓女的特权。这就是他不仅仅成为报纸所有者的地方。他成为了一个主要的新闻制造者。
It is the disapproval and derision of the British people. Well, unbelievable excitement. What a, what a cliffhanger. And if you want to hear all five subsequent episodes, then you can do that by going to The Restis History.com and signing up there. But for now, I will say goodbye. Goodbye. people of the past 50 years. Rupert Murdoch. I think you can argue that he is the most consequential figure of the second half of the 20th century. He holds power longer than anyone else in our time. And it's meaningful power. It's phenomenal power. Power without responsibility, the prerogative of the harlot throughout the ages. This is where he becomes not just a newspaper owner. He becomes a major newsmaker.
去他妈的出版商。带给他八卦总是有溢价的。我不知道你所说的低端市场和高端市场是什么意思。当你那样说话时，那是多么英国阶级歧视的势利。你怎么得到它并不重要。实际上，老实说，无论它是真是假，都没有太大区别。一场巨大、巨大的丑闻正在酝酿中。这是工业化的、非法的活动，我认为这才是真正触动公众和事情的地方。
Fuck Daker Publish. There is always a premium on bringing him gossip. I don't know what you mean by down market and upmarket. That is so English class-ridden snobbery when you talk like that. How you get it doesn't make any difference. Actually, to be perfectly honest, whether it's true or not, doesn't make much difference. There is a massive, massive scandal brewing. This was industrial, illegal activity, and that I think is what really cuts through to the public and things.
你们这些人真的很糟糕。我只想说一句话。这是我一生中最谦卑的一天。没有福克斯新闻就没有唐纳德·特朗普。他的梦想一直是选举一位美国总统。苦涩的讽刺是，那竟然是唐纳德·特朗普。伙计，他厌恶的人。他正在征服世界。
You people are really, really bad. I would just like to say one sentence. This is the most humble day of my life. There is no Donald Trump without Fox News. His dream was always to elect a president of the United States. The bitter irony is that that turned out to be Donald Trump. Man, he detests. He is conquering the world.
没有什么比这种有条不紊、一步一步接管一切的进展更少的了。要了解更多信息，只需在您获取播客的任何地方搜索《其余就是政治》。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
There's nothing less than this methodical step-by-step progress to take over everything. To hear more, just search the rest is politics wherever you get your podcasts. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
除了这种有条不紊、循序渐进地接管一切的方法之外，别无他法。想了解更多信息，请在您获取播客的任何平台搜索“The Rest Is Politics”。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。